[Applause]
strong female don't need no man but
chooses to have one
right you don't need one you choose one
i choose i choose very wisely you did
yeah sometimes
that's nice to hear
best crew in the game best crew in the
game
[Applause]
yeah sorry uh we're late i know it's a
meme but
this illness got the best of me i'm
feeling better today
okay best illness in the game
you're the illest
you know uh i took another covid test
this morning just to be sure
it was negative
and um thank you
but i feel a little loopy because i've
been i've been uh on so much medicine
what are you taking that cold medicine
hits hard man it takes me like a week to
get over that yeah um i was taking the
it's not nyquil it's a different one uh
something flu stereo flu
theraflu yeah i have electron flu
i've been taking a combination of uh
theraflu and ivermectin
it won a nobel prize didn't you hear
yeah it's good for everybody just
jamming insulin into just for the hell
of it
how dare you tell me ivermectin's not
for the common cold it will not it won a
nobel prize they won the nobel prize
but that being said guys
we've got a great show here today
including a gender reveal
that uh you will not want to miss
just so you know pre-show i put up a
poll in youtube which by the way youtube
has polls in the chat now which is very
cool
and uh it's sitting at 73 percent girl
is the guest from the audience
interesting well that was our guest
whole our whole family everyone was like
girl girl girl
why did you think it was a girl you love
because of um
there was like there's no reason
oh yeah the symptoms of this pregnancy
were different yeah it's a little
different uh like people say with a boy
you're like more
like the stomach grows out more and with
a girl you're more wide and i think i am
more white this time
and then
my food cravings have been completely
different like with theodore i wanted
hamburgers which i never do
and i miss those days
and then this time i don't want to see
me at all yes i'm like i fully don't eat
meat at all
but how can that be indicative of gender
like women don't like me you know what i
mean
oh and also i read that um
there's this is actually backed up by
some data
that for some reason
uh female babies
tend to survive more like stressful
pregnancies like if you're under a lot
of stress
there's more
evidence of female babies
yeah than male babies surviving is it is
it because
male babies tend to not survive it's
because girls are our bosses oh girl
boss babies yeah oh okay robots
there
baby
in the hardest of times
okay not bianca not you bianca
everyone bite you
yeah oh by the way today's episode is
sponsored by scentbird
hellofresh honey
and mint mobile frank kavanagh we do
this
when he hears all my sponsors
oh look speaking of uh
legendary figures
[Applause]
what what number white claw is that on
are you on
line baby
what number is that for you
number one oh number one crack it open
let's get started
it is the weekend after all yep here
congrats on your child now gabe can i
ask you a personal question
sure
are you into uh extreme close-ups of
women's genitals
oh
[Laughter]
because we saw some of your like tweets
and we were like wow well gabe you know
he's not shy about uh his preferences
there so
it's secret you know i don't know it's
public
stuff yeah actually actually you should
be careful with the instagram likes too
because
it's been a while but i'm pretty sure
there's a way for people to see what you
like on instagram as well
[Laughter]
yeah so
just be careful with those likes
look but don't like
it it's better that way
but it could have been worse gabe it
could have been worse it could have been
some really weird [ __ ] that's hard to
explain
right
oh yeah oh
so yeah gotta learn new things you know
i learned something new every day yeah
absolutely that's what life's all about
yeah even a veteran i always learn
something new every day yeah and that's
why we love you
all right well gabe um
just keep taking care
and how many white claws you gonna kick
back tonight
maybe three or four tonight three or
four
this is just my pre uh preamp just one
today all right just kick it back keep
getting them back it's friday baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] baby
[Music]
all right
hit that yeah
all right thanks gabe take care buddy
all right
[ __ ]
gabe
what club gabe on cameo
i didn't know you were gonna hit him
with that
i do
i had to do it
somebody donated ten dollars and said
let gabe jacket in peace
i'm not telling you
i did him a favor just listen to your
life somebody had to step in and tell
him yeah there's actually a big of you
to just know
on a giant but it's true imagine if he
was liking i mean there's a lot of porn
out there that's not so easy [ __ ] fly
my head did we okay now the fly thing's
not a joke anymore yes there's like a
full-on infant station in both offices
yeah yeah i actually want to clear
ethan's name because
we have exactly the same situation now
at the time
because it's already loaded maybe
oh his guts are everywhere
i busted that [ __ ] but there's so many
of them there's just an unstoppable
force
and nathan doesn't come to our office no
doggies and no fruit
oh if you ask them i'd be like well you
live with ethan
well we have like
40 traps coming and uh and we've got
these electric uh
little bats or rockets i have an
electric bracket
you push the button and it supercharges
and then we also have the bug assault
which is my honestly it's hard to beat
the bug assault yeah i mean it takes a
little more finesse but um
but it's very satisfying yeah yeah so
like this is easier
it it is but it's also not because like
the bugs on the table and you gotta get
it sure but this thing like here you see
this little map it depends on the
see this like look at this he has no
he's no
there's no
escape accuracy
there's a fly in your head i swear to
god
oh my god really wait what dumbledom
do you guys are serious yeah it's on the
boat
i did that to cam earlier
[Laughter]
yeah it's pretty bad over here
so
anyway yeah
a quick shout out to
girl boss ela cline
thank you
the teddy fresh smokey bear collab that
one of our fans
predicted weirdly all right they were
right did we ever get that guy's contest
to give him a hat or something we did
okay
yeah all these purchases
help fund
the
uh
united
[Music]
usf
service forest service yeah yeah
i told you guys to write it out
like people are supposed to guess
yeah i'll have all the money goes
no no not all the money just back it up
part of the money goes
yeah so oh wow there's a lot sold out
already here
this one's sold out
nice
nice
oh and i want to announce that we have a
few new restocks oh yeah i just noticed
these are back the appeal sweater this
is the last restock
this is officially the last restock
this is the ela klein original that's
been in high demand ever since when did
this come back out just today this is
the third time oh yeah
yeah today this is a very special item
never to come back
love that sweater by the way only a girl
boss like you could ever
but anyway you know go check it out
teddyfresh.com
and the women's rape mock knight i know
a lot of people asked about which one
yeah
that's a nice one too
work it work it
work it work get so that's that there it
is
whoop there it is
whoop there it is oh there it is oh
here's the restock list patchwork knit
zip up split tee uphill sweater women's
rib striped quarter three socks back
zach speaking of which you remember you
guys remember how we tried to get zach
to win that mayo contest that was rigged
by barcelo all right straight up [ __ ]
rigged [ __ ] they're stealing it
excuse me allegedly
in minecraft
no what was craft mayo gonna [ __ ] sue
me
yeah they [ __ ] me
yeah well at any rate they sent you they
promised you a consolation prize and you
got it well it wasn't exactly what they
uh promised to send what did they
promise to send you they promised what
was it your supply of mayonnaise dan
yeah of course yes for the message
so right they sent me uh a
letter
um thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you for hopping in a
mayo endorsement fund while it was a
bummer you didn't make it all the way a
bummer that's how they're gonna put it i
wanna say thanks with a gift card
for a year supply of craft mayonnaise
and it's only a hundred dollars so i
guess that's a [ __ ] way
how much does a big jar of mayo cost huh
a big one
a craftsman specifically right let's say
craft mayo
jar
yeah
for a year yeah it doesn't make sense
it's like they're assuming you don't eat
it that much
they're assuming he's he's not a fan of
mayo yeah i took a [ __ ] bath in it
so 48 uh fluid ounces i mean that's
fairly big it's not like huge but it's
like a sizable jar is uh five dollars
and 42 cents at walmart that's a lot of
bananas you're gonna get is that a
hundred dollars worth though you're
gonna get 20 of those 20 20
48 fluid ounces
yeah i guess that's gonna last i guess
well despite the fact
it was still very nice they sent me a
gift card um but they can still go [ __ ]
themselves
too late too little
too little so how does it work the gift
card only works for the mayonnaise no no
it's like it's like a visa gift card
gotcha
yeah so oh so you can use it anywhere
you use it on helmets
that's exactly what i'm gonna do make
sure you get your helmet
that's such a good idea bro
such a good idea i'll just take a
picture of a bunch of helmets
or you could buy a hundred dollar rolex
gift card like i got 50 theirs you know
so it's 150 now you're well on your way
my friend so thank you craft mayonnaise
but [ __ ] you
wow
yeah and by the way regarding the
billboard i'm on board listen i've been
waiting for someone to tell me what to
pay for
the
the gag you know the gag was only really
going to be good if we could do it
across the street from the official one
and they ended up when they did it they
only did it for one day did you know
that for 15 minutes
wait really yeah oh i thought yeah
they got you remember the winner gets a
billboard so we got a hold of the people
that managed that campaign
because we were looking to put up a
billboard across from theirs they said
it was a digital billboard and it was
only up for 15 minutes 15 minutes
the poor guy that won who
he barely got to see it he barely got to
[ __ ] see it that sounds like false
advertising
what you got to say about that
josh
well i think i personally think that
a billboard would still be cool
no matter where it is okay
i don't know why everyone you guys are
dragging your heel i say damn i'm gonna
buy you a tank to sit in well i don't
know if i wanna this is so much
duplicated zach i want to buy you a
billboard oh it's only fun
i look like i'm not like you guys make
me look like a lot of money
and i'm gonna write you an email
a b you're getting a jeff's done [ __ ]
up
and that's all i promise you go oh well
oh wait my contact doesn't work at
instagram
anymore yeah exactly
and so i wrote another email to um
who'd i write an email to i don't know
who you wrote an email too
so
that left the job
great somewhat recently they gave you
they replied and said here's somebody
else that you can reach out to right
wasn't that what happened and then you
sent an email to them
no it's a little even less direct than
that okay yeah
it was less direct than that but ian you
know i did everything i could did you
send it yes of course i said did you get
a reply
email date that's all i promised
i did exactly as i promised wait so you
sent it to the guy who doesn't work at
instagram no no no i said what about
twitter didn't you have someone at
twitter
yes ian doesn't have a twitter he's not
active on twitter i think we gotta
hold on let me
try to find my uh
let me try to find the email i sent all
right
here i would call that uh
in the meantime uh let's see okay so
yeah there was another person i found
yeah
who worked
and i emailed them i emailed them and i
said hey
i know so and so left i was wondering if
you could give me another partner
manager that could help me with
something
that was september 10th no response
i've done it i've done everything i can
ian damn
[ __ ] fly
that's all i promise
hmm
so like if i got a billboard does it
have to be mayo related or it could be
anything
are you just wanting to promote your
show i mean it should be mail related
that's fine would you put on it no i
i've always thought it was a hellman's
app you're trying to promote like a show
or something no no
i'm just curious we all know what he'd
promote
before he promotes every day on his
instagram what's that oh cameo yeah he'd
be like
i kind of like that yeah it's still good
and i mean i still would like to do the
helmets theme i think that'd be really
fun listen guys from now on all your
requests gotta go to shannon oh it's
true and
it's gonna happen
right that's true
i got a personal assistant so
i'm a changed man now
i get [ __ ] done now boy
like yesterday shannon reminded me 20
times to sign some documents and i'm so
thankful that it doesn't have to be me
guess who signed it
me baby
that's such a throwback
love you got the fly net on your head
yeah i came prepared today the flight
has been pretty bad lately they get you
in sweden too
yeah they they travel through the
internet apparently i don't know man
this office is so [ __ ] infected that
even love is getting it
yeah so um
oh speaking of ian since he wants to
trash me
[Laughter]
well here's ian in high school so
whatever dude
explain that
that's not me
i call that
fraud some other insulators advertising
sorry guys i'm coughing so can someone
bring me a tissue so you can cover my
mouth
yeah thank you
i'm just kidding there's nothing wrong
with how you look i mean you look great
yes there is what's wrong
there is what's wrong with it well i
mean
there looks like there's a dead animal
on my head that
probably caused some fly problems that
was the fashion at the time
yeah there was a smosh cut bro yeah did
you watch smosh thank you baby
no but uh
i know it was popular you know the biebs
the beads haircut oh right the beef had
that cut
the dying jet black
oh it might be a bit of a regrettable oh
that's
black
yeah wow
that's
that's hot topic super store member
right there
what grade well at least you're not one
of those that like picked in high school
you know
this is what smosh was at you're looking
better with age yeah that's crazy yeah
that hair is unacceptable
it's wild to think that everyone was
just cruising with that yeah you've ate
you've aged like fine wine my man i
appreciate that i always say ian's
getting younger
like even look at the start of the show
he looks older than he does now that's
funny
well i thought thank you thank you you
got benjamin slater
appreciate that no i came in that day
that was
uh
i had braces
and
the day i got the braces off i went and
i dyed my hair black and i got these new
glasses and in my mind i was like
baby this is a fire rebrand i'm coming
in with
oh my goodness
not quite
what can i say i mean those these years
are embarrassing for all these they are
so embarrassing
this is the emo version
[Music]
those of us who were embarrassed in high
school end up being the most [ __ ] up
people yes because you need that
humility then or you will grow up and be
turned into someone like you know ryan
kavanaugh or keemstar or something
like it just doesn't go good if you you
need humility in high school
i love that one yeah everyone loves
that's a great one
um people are calling me out for being a
hypocrite
there's exposed videos ela what's new
i had tissue on the desk this one is
very little apologize to crowder
immediately
well listen at least
you know what i'm using the tissue for
i'm sick what can i do
i will not apologize to the
you
crowder
have to think about it
doesn't have to think about it i guess i
made fun of crowder for having tissue on
his desk for to wipe away the tears
i mean he wasn't sick as far as i was
aware
i thought ethan was a stand-up guy
wrong
oh this is i'm actually been looking
forward to wendy williams generated a
new meme though
she's got like super power
in that field
oh do we have the one of her do hitting
the um
the vape yeah okay good yeah because
that one's really good too so apparently
this is the thing she does um
she's been doing these shows from home
and watching casually
lights up a [ __ ] slim gym
wait why is she doing wait what tv
why is she doing it from home the other
day
yeah
and that would be matt barnes dude that
lighting is so depressing what is going
on
this is the saddest [ __ ] i ever seen why
is her room so dark you're doing a show
she's sitting in a dark ass room
lighting a slim jim on fire with the
lighter
i mean then
what would you think about that
oh her setup
yeah we love dan i don't know i mean i
guess they probably had to do it on
relatively short notice but even then i
mean
it doesn't
it doesn't look like they're dark
they're turning the light on i just
don't think there's any lighting going
on at all yeah i mean
okay what a slim jam is what this is
something
this here we got some i'm going to so we
got the saying
it's you know
basically the worst
i mean it's just mechanically separated
chicken
yeah
why is she lighting it it's beef pork or
no
yeah beef pork and chicken
right so it's the whole kitchen sink
it's got it all and so what she likes to
do apparently is
cook it with a lighter and before taking
a bite what and glory looks like she's
cooking up some heroin though
look at that
she's dude this woman is making drugs
right
now they're not married
she's she wants to marry
fisher but
you know because of corona they had to
cancel the weather
you believe this [ __ ] at least they've
got each other
remember she was running around can you
believe i might expect to actually
listen to what she's saying anybody has
anyone ever done that
is she trying to sanitize this isn't the
first no this isn't the first time i've
heard of people
heating up slim jims like that but
during the show well yeah obviously
that's it's definitely the first time
i've seen it in theory
heating the slim jim
well i mean it's i don't know make it
more melty do you want to try yeah
lighter right there no but i feel like i
feel like there's a different reason
like
maybe they're sanitizing it or something
because you remember when you used to
like share
there's way too many like chemicals in a
slim jim for it to need
sanitation in any way i thought that it
would look like an edible bit there
crisp it up a little bit because you
know there's like skin on a slim jim
and you have to like break through it to
eat it she didn't cook it for that long
though
i'm not going to eat it because you
cannot eat it yeah no i wouldn't
recommend that i've been dying to try
this everyone's getting in on this
i know this is true but this article
says the slim jim inventor has died of
coronavirus just as a oh perhaps i don't
oop and i oop
well this one goes out to him
also this is like a butane lighter isn't
just like butane all over it no
yeah probably
it tastes a little faster
like smell that
no thanks
eating up slim jim with water
no chilling sounds pleased
one is on to it
well when i search for anything about
slimgen and lighter it's just wendy
stuff that comes up
i just don't know
how an individual if someone decides to
start doing that
yeah again i feel like i have
heard of people doing that before oh
oh
good that's interesting right
ooh
so maybe you know we're
too quick to judge
she's awesome i actually do think so
what is it what is it like it's softer
oh interesting
melty
real this slaps dude
it's a lot of work though
i'm just surprised she's uncomfortable
doing this in public
probably move the plastic a little
further away it's definitely going to
melt on that adds to the flavor bro
the more
i want to increase my chances of colon
cancer as much as possible
it's when it's not the chewing it's that
you gotta not do that okay i'm gonna
lose it
i'm just gonna lose
i'm seeing like two youtube videos of
people doing it and they call it a
slimgen barbecue
a barbecue it's a slim jim a bar
it's like crap a slim jim crab egg
if you look at discord ian just sent
another clip of her talking about it i
guess she's she's done it before on her
show really yeah
oh my god
here we go
and your lady have been together for two
and a half years they're doing it
together
now you have two children my mouth is
watering good they're smoking cracks
look how they're doing this oh good
mm-hmm good eating
i wouldn't just sit here without any
explanation dare you judge her no
i have many things to learn from you i
need my own segment of my weirdness he's
a sound man he's a stunt man yeah did
you meet him um on a movie set or you
should cut it off because they they
claim sometimes all right
all right i'm out of this somebody take
this because ethan oh you're not gonna
you're not gonna try it we'll get back
she actually can't i can't eat it while
pregnant
there's a fly here that needs to be
extremely you can't eat deli meats or
any
did not know sausage
thank you baby
you still might get on that guy yeah
i would be too
i added the other wendy meme in the doc
right below there so there's a there's
another wendy meme yep who we love so
well
um
she got covered right
yeah and here she was caught vaping
but look at her face just why wendy why
do you
she comes out of the hospital
right
wendy died
i think that's actually just her leaving
her apartment okay well she's not
looking good
she's having a rough time with it
straight hitting that baby
and her face too like i mean
i know she has a condition where her
eyes are like bigger
graves disease
but that's they seem like she's actually
yeah maybe her eyes are just a meme
machine i don't know
what do you call that av
graves disease
is it it's like a uh thyroid thing yeah
is that what you were talking about pete
davidson
no he has a different um yeah he's a
different one his uh crohn's thrones
yeah
he makes him sexy apparently that he
shits a lot
i [ __ ] a lot nobody calls me sexy
yeah open your eyes wider
it's not that he has wide eyes it said
he has sunken eyes oh okay
i believe it was uh
so do i from lack of sleep but nobody's
that's true
oh and then here's another meme at the
top of the show ela yes
so we've talked i mean for those of you
are familiar gary delibate from the
howard stern show has the the what's
considered the worst first pitch of all
time
um
i'll show you guys that
and interestingly someone else has
basically challenged him
this is so iconic because
for any pitcher it takes
strikes to cement a legend this guy baba
boy from the howard stern show
was building up to this moment his whole
life talking about it prepping for it
practicing he's a huge flip uh baseball
fan
and he came out and threw the first
pitch and it was it's considered to be
the worst first fish of all time look at
that
and look at look he's just humiliated he
knows
yeah
the announcer actually said oh jesus
yeah
it was all over the news everyone was
clowning on him like wow
but
he'll be happy to know
conor mcgregor
topped him
by throwing the worst pitch ever
i actually think it's far worse than
than gary's
so here it is
and he's an athlete and gary's just a
producer right
so here you go conor mcgregor how to
play baseball okay boom
way out of there
not even close
look at how tight the sport coat is
[Laughter]
it looks easy when you're in the ring
doesn't it connor look at how tight the
sport coat is
it is quite tight
yeah so you know people have been saying
yeah his career is over that i think his
career is over now
yeah i mean that's just shameful
i know he's not like a baseball player
i saw him say that 50 cent was worse oh
for real 50 cent okay wait wait connor
said 50 70 yeah because people call it
the worst and it was like how dare you
it's actually in there it's in the it's
in the dark we were kind of debating at
the office a little bit oh this is so
fascinating but okay so 50 cent is i
mean that's kind of even less forgivable
because at least connor's like irish
but fit but you know what
wait
what's the
because baseball is the american pastime
oh he said it's american i see
you know that i don't know that they
play baseball in ireland right okay
probably not right yeah probably
the thing is if you know you're this
jackson you don't go do it or you prac
you practice first pitch you don't go
[Laughter]
you can't do it
does he know he can't throw a ball and
he still goes out and does it
what do you guys think about gibson i
guess he doesn't care
i have to assume
it's pretty embarrassing i don't know
any thoughts
i think he kind of just released too
early but yeah yeah released too early i
mean he doesn't want to throw a ball
yeah it does look worse to me than this
one
releasing the throwing left is just a
weird thing right
that is true that's just a weird thing
what can you say it's something about uh
them going to the mets you know
i think he opened up his first pitch
because that's gary was at the met
stadium too
he never had a choice between uh playing
for the match i could i could i feel
like i could throw that right down the
center and i'd be willing to prove it
i feel like i could prove it right now
right down the center
we have a baseball bat somewhere our
baseball ball no we don't we don't have
a real baseball here
what we have is like throw it right down
i'll prove right now that i'm more elite
of an athlete than conor mcgregor
we could set it up for next week because
yeah i don't we don't have the official
uh stuff here the only baseball we have
is a little t-ball baseball it's like
squishy
stop it
nobody will care next week
then
what do you guys are saying check out
mariah carey's picture oh this is
awesome
yo keep the recommendations coming
because i love this carries in the
discord we have one for pouchy in here
uh oh
yeah he recently went pretty bad oh my
god i just can't get these people you
can't go out there and throw the first
page if you don't if you know you can't
throw you've got to know what you're
doing at least
just throw the ball a few times
she's not there to play
this is worse than pearl harbor for
america
oh she played softball while here let's
look at jenna marbles see i'm fascinated
by these
jenna marbles first pitch
if she's in the sports it doesn't
surprise me she's got a good pitch
wow that's a famous youtube dodgers
stadium
[Music]
dude somebody invite me i'll throw it
i'll nail that [ __ ]
right down the [ __ ] line
i will i got a good arm
mark ruby marco rubio just threw a pitch
at a cincinnati's red game what really
yeah how are these guys all getting
these crazy ass i want to throw a pitch
let's hit up the dodgers
wow
killed that beautiful she killed that
that is a s tier pitch right down the
line i send carly rae jepsens in the
discord one more time
damn
wow
jenna i think carly reyes is the worst
i've ever seen oh interesting i love
this keep them coming this is to be so
entertaining
so this next one is carly rae jepsen who
the [ __ ] is that
she's a a music
artist pretty big one
she's saying call me maybe
call me maybe
maybe hey
i just brought you
and this song
[Laughter]
all right well here we go of the ball
game saw her warming up
okay
this is not good
just say no and you can't do it
if somebody invited you to throw the
first pitch would you no exactly or
practice throw the ball a few times
it seems scary though
someone get me a ball
any ball come on guys
i'm gonna prove i want to prove the ball
game
saw her warming up oh my goodness listen
all right let's break let's bring here
give me this
where are you going to throw it yeah
what can i throw it so you guys can see
that we need to go out there can we get
a camera out there
yeah move that out there
and then measure with the distance on
the mlb stadium between the mounds and
the catchers okay
that's a tennis ball this isn't official
at all
you'll know if i know how to throw a
ball
i mean i'm doing the best i can dan what
[ __ ] you want from me
dan's already building in excuses 60
feet 6 inches
60 feet measure it they're saying check
out david dobrik
david dobrik and tio vaughn did a good
one okay wait everybody's got to do this
now we're going to measure everybody's
skill
this is
everybody yep everybody's going to throw
this ball down
dave so wait david dobrik through
no i'm going to stand up and get over
there everybody's going to do it we're
going to get to the bottom of this
david dobrik first pitch where's my
first pitch invite
ready resin link red link too i think
you need like a manager yeah i think
you need to like network that [ __ ] yeah
i don't have a manager or anything
well you you don't like it no i [ __ ]
hate jojo siwa
say what
the girl jojo
i don't see david first pitch
i'm posting them in the description oh
okay so
i'll just go there
um
let's see here we've got uh
rhett and link yeah
let's see apparently how do they do they
throw twice
oh people aim high because maybe we just
wanted them to do this oh yeah they're
pretty dangerous i don't want it to
bounce or whose ever can you want it to
bounce so you don't want to bounce it
but you don't like it
here we go
that wasn't great come on don't flatter
them it bounced they didn't even make it
to the no it's just how the balls went
they did a little little cross
christmas yeah i appreciate that but
they're they were style flair
they weren't great don't hear me getting
ready to throw up
first pitch joe this is not didn't even
make it to the catcher
no and i think you'd have to think about
it it's not that it's not as bad as some
of the other things you've seen
because it will i think it's carly ray
i think that's the king so far
you don't want to bounce it but you
don't want to air mail it over there no
but i don't think this is interesting
they don't look strong so it looks like
link had a good pitch and rhett kind of
bounced a little bit obviously
but all in all you know
nothing to be embarrassed about
um
david dubrick
dubrick dubrick first pitch
[Music]
baby
that's fine
no problem yeah no problem there yeah
if the catcher is able to catch it then
you're good right um
that's the goal
yeah i mean
jenna marbles had a perfect pitch it was
like in the strike zone
that was genuinely impressive yeah we're
witnessing ethan turn into his dad
this is it it's happening i actually
don't care about baseball but i've
watched enough and played when i was a
kid
okay i have it all measured out all
right
here we go guys
somebody just donated five bucks oh
they're saying um mlb is notorious for
claiming so
[ __ ] them come from fair use [ __ ] a fan
just donated five bucks and said they
have an end with the san diego padres
they could set you up diego
do not dare step in that stadium
are they the rivals of the dodgers yeah
obviously pretty big
i thought the giants were the rivals my
child would divorce
[Music]
appreciate the offer but apparently that
so here's bernie by the way taking the
field what do you think about this hilo
love it
oh underhand
[Music]
oh that's not at first he did a softball
pitch but he's still out there
oh he's hustling
bernie's hustling he's like weirdly
athletic have you seen the videos of him
shooting hoops he's like really good no
no i haven't yeah bernie is like
he i guess he played someone small in
college and he's like pretty legit he's
got hoops yeah
hmm
send me that disc is this almost set up
the uh
oh do you want to do it comes the first
pitch who's gonna catch
all right here i go
i'm going to step out in the back
there's no mic over there so i guess
i'll
help narrate what's going on over here
you got the feed right ian
okay
all right he's walking out he's walking
out to the field
the puppies are following him
there's some dispute
ethan's realizing how far it is
a little bit farther than he realized
he even says it's really far
yeah it is isn't it
all right here we go oh my god
oh
oh
oh it caught it
okay wow
i'm impressed
i'm impressed
you good
they're just playing baseball now
what
and abe just threw the ball and hit the
rolls-royce good job
he says now for a smoker okay i guess
we're getting around too let's see let's
see the fastball
pull up pull up pepper on this one
let's see it
here we go
oh whoa
okay
i've never even seen ethan attempt to
play so there's something on that one
surprise not bad
not bad
when do you when do you practice this
i don't know i used to throw a ball
around when i was a kid when you were
like five yeah and you remember
it's in your listen it's in my blood
muscle memory
all right who wants to try next um we
are way over for the ads just all right
let me do the ads and then we'll get it
on 45
but thank you are people impressed that
was very impressive um
[Music]
there was a cut and that it's fake
need a real baseball um
a real baseball would be easier the
tennis balls we didn't see it rigged
no guys honestly all something aside
that fastball was pretty impressive
it was directly aimed at me like it was
really good there you go thank you got
the accuracy nathan is uh also
always surprisingly good at um
shooting like whenever we went to oh
yeah this is the shooting range
he's really good at it he's got that
gamer aim
exactly
[Laughter]
all right let's do some collabs now or
some sponsors and i want to see you guys
throw some balls
really hell yeah let's get it no
practice
i don't know how excited they are about
it
well
i don't care you really are turning into
your day yeah it's fun it's fun let's
see come on worst [ __ ] best [ __ ]
oh my god excuse me upset
scentbird guys you like scentbird right
elo yeah
it's really cool
uh
business model
scentbird is a fragrance subscription
service that gives you the opportunity
to shop from over 600 brands it's a
flexible subscription so you can skip
any month without penalties send birds
let you choose a new designer fragrance
to try every month for just 16 bucks
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there's no surprise
they have perfumes and colognes and a
lot of unisex options
[Laughter]
yeah so you know they're like all these
designer perfumes like all these
designer brands like gucci wasaki's uh
chanel and all this
very expensive
so semper you're basically get to try it
um every month for just 16 bucks
with each fragrance you'll get a 30 day
supply so you can try it out before
committing to a full bottle you can
upgrade to receive a two or three
products a month as well
sandberg carries top designer brands
like prada gucci versace as well as
indie labels like vince camuto
the harmonist and confessions of a rebel
[Music]
all of them are 100 authentic they work
directly with the brands what do you
think dan yeah here's uh
let's see which one is which
comes in these cool little twos which
really one of the best parts little
tubes
and then you pull it out and there you
go this one is a prada
this one's a clone
smells really good
sick this service is really cool yeah
the versace one is the one i like
starches eros that's how you pronounce
it yeah so really cool product really
cool service make sure to use our coupon
code h3 and get 30 off at scentbird link
is in the description again that's 30
off with code h3 at sendbird
and that's going to be just 11 for your
first month thank you thank you peace
and love
hello freush
hello fresh
fall is busy people but hello fresh
recip uh recipes are gonna save you time
you'd otherwise be spent
planning meals shopping chopping
you're gonna get back to what matters
which is live laugh love
if you're not live laugh loving
then you're wasting your time on this
planet
uh they got a big family friendly menu
is a big win for back-to-school season
with easy delicious recipes for drama
free dinners here's the deal with
hellofresh they send you
beautiful portioned out meals with the
recipe you don't have to think about it
dude you don't even have to
play that down by jack
hellofresh is like this
no i
programmed music as the same one
[Music]
oh you can't play crowd no no no
you can't even think about it dude
yeah so they send you the meal they send
you the
ingredients all pre-portioned out they
should tell you how to cook it so you
can be making gourmet beautiful healthy
meals you see a fly
oh [ __ ] it's on the monitor no don't
shoot the monitor oh no no no that's bad
that's bad okay don't do that my monitor
i got it ethan oh my god
it flew away
this flies are like monitored no
anyway hello fresh
give me your head you your does your
hello fresh need some seasoning i got
some
scratch the lens do you see any
difference
i guess we'll find out later yep
looks fine meanwhile the fly is still on
my computer
these flies have like nine lives
it's on your shoulder don't zap her
don't zap
oh get fried [ __ ]
that's actually more satisfying even
than the guard
[Music]
anyway speaking of hello fresh
[Music]
anyone got any picks who's been doing
hello fresh
i don't know if we have any fresh up
ones there's uh the one that we showed
before yeah let's pop it up okay
so
anyway you cook this up in like 10 15 20
depends on the recipe it's easy clean up
it's easy to make bada bing bada boom
here's our offer for you guys go to
hellofresh.com slash after dark 14 and
use the code after doug 14 for up to 14
free meals including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com
slash after dark 14.
that's and there's a reason why
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit people it's because of the bad you
got a photo for me no we'd have no photo
be trying to find it
peace and love the read's over
we'll pop it up later
honey
we all shop online and we've all seen
that promo
code field that taunts us at checkout
but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
right honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one to find it
fines to your car honey supports over 30
000 stores online ranging from tech
gaming products
gaming products popular fashion brands
and even food delivery what
how much money do we save on honey
a lot
uncar ungodly uncountable thousands yeah
i mean it's a it's a power
you install it you buy [ __ ] online and
when you're at checkout it goes blood of
being guess what i just found a code
saved you 20 30 50
it's a win-win i mean there's nothing to
lose here imagine you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites when you check
out the honey button drops down all you
have to do is click apply coupon wait a
few seconds honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site and bada bing
honey finds a coupon you're gonna watch
the price drop
we save money all the time you save like
50 bucks buying jeans the other day
yeah it really works
especially it starts on websites you you
kind of figure out
but honey traps yeah
but um
i always check it i mean might as well
honey has found it's over 17 million
members
uh saved uh
over two billion dollars in savings come
on now
you don't really have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally free the stalls in a few
seconds and by getting you gonna be
doing a solid and supporting this
podcast i would never recommend
something i don't use so get honey for
free at jointhoney.com
h3ad that's joinhoney.com h3ad thank you
thank you peace and love peace and love
[Music]
did we get that photo
yeah i have uh abs babies sad ass
they're familiar with your favorite one
this is what abe said
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well if you want to see the ingredients
the first photo has
all of them separate you just gotta
imagine the in between i can't do it
[Music]
there you go
just shove all that in there
in your mind
clean though clean grill marks
fantastic
and finally mint mobile
mint mobile is oh [ __ ] not there
mint mobile is here to destroy the
competition
after years of fine print contracts
getting ripped up by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything is
that there's always a catch so when i
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium wireless services that started
just 15 bucks a month i thought what's
the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their service hello yeah it all made
sense you know what the answer is there
isn't a catch there isn't one it's just
that good mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless services online only so by
cutting out the retail stores there
knows crazy overhead costs to get passed
down to you in the form of mysterious
fees
instead mint just passes on the sweet
savings directly to you
dan's been using mint mobile
it's just as good as the big uh it sure
is it's the same [ __ ] probably better
yeah why not yeah
it's it's it's the same [ __ ] at this
point they they all using the same
networks anyway it's like not a mystery
so it's just a better price for people
looking for extra savings mint mobiles
offers premium wireless for just fifteen
dollars a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and tax high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts and if you're not 100 satisfied
mid mobile has you covered with their 7
day money back guarantee switch to mit
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 a month you get your
new wireless play for just 15 bucks a
month and to get the plan shipped
straight to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com that's mint mobile
dot com slash after dark cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com after dark thank you
all right
so we have the jet thank you guys
um so we have the gender reveal ready
but i do want to see you guys throw i
want to see your
throat audience really want to see the
gender reveal should we do it after
yeah we can do it after
you all are stepping up though
you guys don't want to throw not really
no oh come on we i want to see it wow
none of us said that we were going to be
able to do it no one said nobody's like
bragging about their ability i guess i
was the only one yeah i'm down i'm down
to try it zach can do it but i just want
to see where the abilities at it's fun
it's not fun if you're the only one
saying it's fun
[Laughter]
it reminds me of like well because
they're afraid they're going to throw a
shitty bulb yeah and then it's
embarrassing but it's not funny you're
reminding me like when someone is good
at singing and they're like let's go
karaoke it's so fun
it's fun i know someone likes a great
comparison keep suggesting a karaoke
segment it's not funny
yeah there's someone we used to go
karaoke with and then we would get there
and then he would just sing uh like
actually try to sing right seriously
[Laughter]
like not fun at all
right
yeah zach's been pitching karaoke with
the clients as a segment for like two
years
not the ability just the name literally
the first week i started he was pitching
it
that name is just
but we do have another singer on the
crew now actually so
interesting
smart
answer all right well let's do these so
are you guys ready for the gender reveal
because i have something special i've
been working on people
you do
big project interesting interesting well
i mean the audience is literally i mean
they're just spamming baby emojis and
[ __ ] for the last like 45 minutes so so
guys i i you guys need to follow me
it's planned it's over here everybody
just follow me
yeah off the set
and let's go uh
okay
i feel like this is a ploy
all right guys so as you know
people have been
good you'll understand as you know
people have been going all out
on gender reveals
and
i'm not one to be shown up
so i have an idea i don't know i'm open
to suggestions but i'm pretty set up
mine so maybe like like cupcakes pink oh
yeah cupcakes no
bigger we could do like uh confetti yeah
there's a little confetti cake
burning down half the state of
california and you're suggesting
confetti
are you saying this is a good thing
yes i want people to know exactly i've
been working
on getting
some enriched uranium
you are gonna need to be a few states
over so that we don't get any birth
defects
but i
have an idea
just stand by and uh enjoy the show
all right my friends come gather round
let me present to you
the baby boomer now i've been working
with a few nuclear iranian scientists
that were banished i was able to contact
them on like linkedin i don't know and
this is kind of like my own little
manhattan project what do you guys think
doctor clinton why are you trying to
kill me yeah this is no well we do need
you to be over at at least like wyoming
to not to be safe so that's that'll take
like eight hours okay yeah everyone else
is gonna be yeah yeah that's fine no
they're not gonna die it's just maybe
some slight it's it's a nuclear it is
powered by by splitting the atom so okay
anyway so uh who's ready for the gender
reveal i think don't think it's you know
i'm about it i'm i'm in for this yeah
you don't i'm excited i don't think we
should this is the button no no no no no
no no no no no no no there's right yeah
it's a boy
whoa
there you go it's a boy
everybody the [ __ ]
[Applause]
you guys don't seem to talk
you guys don't seem happy
congratulations
congratulations i guess
yay
we destroyed everything that's a hell of
a way to reveal gender people
i'm watching the chat because they're
behind like 30 seconds
it's blue everybody everyone's so scared
thank you guys thank you
yes
thank you i'm really happy i'm really
excited i think the dynamic of um two
boys is gonna be really precious and
beautiful right they're gonna be best
friends yeah they're homies they're
close in age
that's true that's good
you know
but there's still time for another girl
or two
yeah
well mazel
it's interesting that iranian uh
nuclear scientists are actually really
easy to come by
like they're they just they
they're down a dozen over there yeah
well with the sanctions you know they're
they're looking for work so
and yeah and you know your uranium is
really easy to get to so hopefully i'm
not infertile after that
good chance that will be decent chance
you sure looks pretty cool
yeah thank you ela and you take notes uh
future design
keep it in mind
yeah but i do want to talk about
all the other stuff
we can yeah we should
you want to show the photos oh we have
photos right
so
let me pull up the photos we got these
like advanced 3d dude these are crazy
where is it in the document uh in the
gender reveal section yeah it's towards
the bottom okay
to my eye it's all over it's like jesus
is so far down
some of my ass cracked
what's that
oh hard dog
attacked delivery man
everything okay
can you
i hear him complaining
yeah i went to help out but i think i
might have scared him more when i walked
up with a blue face
you're looking like you're ready to
challenge him to meet you in fortnight
oh yeah shannon is everything all right
okay
okay so anyway
not the scare of the lawsuit incoming
yeah not the scariest dogs in the world
well he didn't say he didn't say he bit
me he said he tried to bite me right but
treader he he he looks scary but he
wouldn't really bite i don't think
alfredo on the other hand he's a killer
yeah so anyway um
here's the photos so we did some like
advanced technology 3d ultrasound where
you can really
see the
details
yeah it's so crazy [ __ ]
so there's the face obviously yeah that
is wild
the doctor goes when we found out the
gender
she goes so there's the two legs and
here's the third leg here
got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
crazy they can do that
yeah
and seeing him move when did in this
kind of view i felt like i can really
tell what it looks like it's crazy
you said he looks just like theodore
yeah i think so
shannon everything okay what happened
oh
[Music]
did they bite him or
okay
she said no for the record
oh those are probably our fly tracks i
kind of want to set this up right now
yeah
so anyway the re actually the reason we
had to go get this super
ultra sound is because
um
well i guess there's some issues with
the baby that we found out yeah so i did
the the third no the second trimester
um
[Music]
checkup that's when we found out the
gender too
but they don't tell you at the moment if
there's any problems or anything but
they're like we'll call you later if
there's any issues
and then i got a call and i was like oh
[ __ ]
um
so there were two things they were
worried about
and one of them is being they told me
the kidney one kidney is not looking
right and then
another issue was um
something with the stomach
so they said there was a calcium
and uh
one of the kidneys was not growing
so
i had to go do another ultrasound and
more blood tests and stuff so i'm still
waiting on some results but we did
another ultrasound and
they did see that the second kidney is
not good
so
um
what it might mean is basically that
you might just have to
live with one kidney which you can do
and that's the best case scenario
um
the worst case is that maybe there's
other complications so we're waiting to
hear
but the on the second examination the
stomach looked
just small not like there was a like i
guess the calcium on the stomach is a
bad is like a sign of a birth defect or
something bad yeah but he so he said he
didn't see it in the second time but he
said that the stomach looked kind of
small so
we'll have to keep checking up to see
that it develops okay
yeah so i guess the first one we got the
first call it was kind of scary like
yeah it was all early in the morning and
i was just like what the [ __ ]
but it sounds like when afterwards we
went to see a specialist
and it seems like the stomach is
probably okay
we're doing all these screenings now to
see if we have any like um
disposition to
birth defects
yeah
but those will probably be negative
hopefully yeah
probably
um so the kid will be so yeah i mean
he'll is he'll definitely be born with
one working kidney yeah like they showed
me the
the normal kidney they're like this is
what it's supposed to look like and you
just see like a black
or like a gray
sack and then there's just one black
thing in it and that's the normal way
that it should look like and then the
other one
looks the same but it has a bunch of
little black things in it
and they're like that's a bunch of like
little cysts and that's not supposed to
look like that
but they said that um
in the past you people
first of all people would just not even
know like a lot of times women didn't do
as many tests so people were just born
like that and they didn't even know they
only had one kidney
and also another thing is that
there was a time where they thought they
need to do a surgery to remove
the bad kidney but they've learned they
don't need to do that so i was really
bro i can't imagine doing a surgery on
it yeah that's horrible yeah
so
it could be all fine it's just kind of
scary you don't even need to do surgery
it just like
gets absorbed into the body
it just shrinks slowly and eventually
disappears
the thing is that's interesting i guess
he can't do like high-intensity sports
yeah or drink alcohol
that one i think is questionable
i guess heavy drinking i didn't ask the
doctor specifically about that one
but
um yeah probably not heavy drinking yeah
i read that online i don't know
but yeah so i mean hopefully that's it
we're gonna do another checkup in four
weeks and if everything develops then
you know best case scenario is that it
will just be the one kidney and
otherwise healthy
and hopefully
there's nothing else
here's a comment my son was born with
one working kidney his left kidney was
polycystic yeah that's exactly what
happened to us it's also the left kidney
it never functioned after birth but the
right kidney grew in size and works for
both he's five years old and so healthy
now love you cool thanks for sharing
there's quite a few messages like that
actually there's yeah a lot well you
know it was when we first got the call i
was worried because it wasn't like there
was just one thing it was like yeah they
were like there's two things there's
like the kidney and the stomach and i
was like oh [ __ ] that that sounds not
good
but i'm glad the specialist kind of
these are more comments because i love
yeah here's another one my sister was
born with only one kidney and she's
perfectly fine her doctor said she will
live a normal life she just can't drink
a lot yeah later in life yeah right
somebody nathaniel says i was born with
one kidney and i've lived a healthy
uh my whole life and can you throw could
you throw a first pitch
us know nathaniel
good thank you guys for sharing your
stories makes me feel better yeah
here's another one isabelle donated 10
said my sister has one kidney she's 16
and is extremely healthy don't over
stress uh she just has to be careful
when playing sports congrats on your
baby
cool
yeah that's good yeah
so yeah we're just kind of hoping and
praying that the stomach's fine
yeah and then well
everything else is good
but there you have it
you know
they kept asking us all these questions
like do you have birth defects i know
it's so stressful and they're like so
does your family has a history of um
yeah
any syndrome syndrome or birth defects
and then she goes what's your husband's
race and she goes he goes full ashkenazi
jew it's like oh
did they really say that
well they kind of did they said he needs
to go do a blood test there's some
specific birth
defect
specific to eskenazi jews but she says
because eel is sephardic then the
chances are really low gotcha but if
like two ashkenazi jews
you're like basically like the uh
targaryens at that point
just like 50 50 chance yep
of uh
yeah
being [ __ ]
so there you go
here's someone who says my best friend
is 36 has one kidney and still drinks
heavily low he'll be good
dare to dream dare to dream
well you know truthfully i do think that
alcoholism is genetic and me and hila
both don't care about alcohol don't
drink at all so i think there's a good
chance that our son won't even care
about alcohol
dare to dream though
don't let one kidney stop you from
achieving your dreams of being an
alcoholic
we drank beer
i drank beer senator and having some
beers i like beers
do you like beer senator do you like
beer senator i like beer
um
trailer trailer trailer one of my best
friends with boring one kidney and ran
track in high school and drinks parties
harder than me there you go
i don't think tracks the issue i think
it's more like football where if some if
you take like a kidney shot you need to
like watch actually physically hurting
where the kid is exactly right makes
sense
although they don't tell you like hey
watch your liver you can't you only have
one liver i mean we have two kidneys
it's a backup
yeah
i guess it's just the fact that you
don't have a backup now i don't have a
backup liver
apparently you can live with like a
quarter of a liver though
so
um
what else the mario movie that shit's
good
oh actually let's do this
okay this was a viral meme i have a
pretty good answer to this i'm very
confident
one actor
and all their movies have to go
between denzel leonardo tom hanks and
robert downey
down
yes robert downey jr
so close
robert downey
jr
no i was thinking i would almost said
robert downsy
oh my god
but i stopped myself and then you said
it well it's fine i didn't say it for
real
i didn't mean to say it
i just say rdj
so who okay so here's what i would do
easily yes
easily yeah
i could [ __ ] live my whole life and
not even know that this [ __ ] was
gone
robert downey that's the right answer
that is the correct answer sealed away
yep life was black i'm sorry
i knew i would disagree with that dude
robert downey jr literally is known for
one series other than that he could [ __ ]
off and i didn't even like the series
that much
like even if you like um avengers and
all that [ __ ]
he still doesn't hold a candle to these
actors
go ahead second i would say denzel
probably couldn't i would not let go of
leo and tom hanks i agree denzel ii you
never know what you're going to get i'd
probably throw tom out second really
his filmography scopes decades of
classes i thought a lot listen i'm with
you robert downey
yeah denzel's got amazing movies are you
kidding me he doesn't not compared to
tom hanks listen i'm not saying that was
an easy choice but i feel like
movies are like part of history yeah he
is movies dan
i like tom hanks i'm not trying to all
right well i like all three of those
before we move on to the second one to
get killed amy do you want to defend
robert downey jr dude without rdj we
don't have the 20 marvel movies and i
don't know those are just i wouldn't
mind that don't threaten me with a good
time don't confront me with a good time
without him maybe cinema would have been
such a [ __ ] show
maybe they'd actually be making good
movies it was like an event i don't know
like me and like 10 of my friends would
all go to the movies and watch it every
time they could have asked someone else
let's be honest there's no one else who
could play iron man as well right now
i mean he's good at i do agree that he
nailed that role but yeah i mean that's
not enough wait isn't the rule
not just they can cast someone else but
the movies don't exist they don't right
yeah yeah
those movies are okay fair enough fair
enough yeah i mean i could dude marvel
move
okay king kong so you're saying one
series so who would you kill then maybe
i don't know i really don't know
[ __ ] kill someone come on i'm
killing tom hanks
so chet doesn't uh
chet was never born
that's interesting
oh yeah people are saying pull this yeah
let me uh i'll set up an audience poll
you know let's make it anyone else uh
disagree with you guys always make me
feel like i'm crazy i uh no i i think
that
i think it's probably a pretty common
sentiment to love robert downey jr but i
i believe the reason this was trending
is because a lot of people were saying
they killed tom hanks really and that to
me is like dude give me a [ __ ] break
tom hanks and leo are the two that you
have to save i agree with that and
between the two i would probably that's
a tough choice because leo's made so
many great movies too but that would
save tom hanks his number one see
i kind of agree with a b on this
i would keep robert downey jr and get
rid of denzel you know what i'm not that
mad about that getting rid of denzel me
too like it's not because i'm just i'm
not i'm like not a marvel fan at all i'm
not an iron man fan but like the dude is
just kind of an icon
yeah for sure it's tough because malcolm
x is one of my favorite movies so and i
love training day all right the poll is
up glory i mean yeah i i could get rid
of denzel that doesn't bother me that
much
i just don't have the same fondness for
the marvel movies that that other people
do this is so cool the youtube call yeah
right saves me from panicking
rdk is actually in an early lead here
with 40
so people are killing uh yeah denzel
seems to be the runner up and it's
actually close actually it's going back
and forth between denzel and you know
what that's that's good that you guys
are on the right path we got to do these
polls before we say anything though like
that's true what are the great movies
that denzel's even like how many great
classics has denzel made remember the
titans remember the titans glory
training day glorious great movie
training days an amazing movie
philadelphia oh yeah it's a great movie
but tom hanks was in that one too so do
you get like a man on fire man on fire
is great
not a classic
there's a flower
like i said i mean on my hair there's a
fly in oh [ __ ]
wait now it's on my head yeah
i gotta do it
looks like that it's starting to lean
towards denzel american gangster
the book of eli
he's just naming every movie he's made
those are all classics they're good
flight america i mean he was good in
flight even though eli
what's the rating on that i don't know
what the book
is the equalizer
yeah
the book of eli didn't was that was like
a horribly
yeah 6.9 i mean not horrible but
certainly nothing new
let's see what's one's life forever it's
denzel for me he's got to go god love
him he's got to go though i think you
might not right now i think denzel's the
one you're killing that's the sorry
denzel that's the way to go
unfortunately you guys want to see tom
hanks imdb i mean this [ __ ] is
ridiculous bro
nobody can hold a candle to this man
life was like a box of chocolates you
know the polar express
uh the lady killer yeah he's made dude
he's made a lot of movies
turner and hooters they're not all good
turner
saving him for his bad movies
why don't they show more but anyway here
alone you've got castaway big force
couple pull 13 which i don't even i
forgot about that one so good catch me
if you can catch me if you can i love
that movie so much it's a good but
dicaprio is in that one too i know
wait why can't i look at all no series
oh
sort by
yeah those i didn't even watch i'm just
purposely naming all these words wait
dan you said you'd get rid of tom skanks
again
it's a for me it's close between tom and
denzel i think they're both great
rdj is the only one that that's like an
easy toss for me
see i i disagree with that forest okay
look at this forest gump saving private
ryan the green mile great movie toy
story catch me if you can toy story
three casts away toys okay toy story we
get it
captain phillips i don't care about that
movie the terminal didn't care for it da
vinci code didn't care for it band of
brothers great [ __ ] show he's not in
that he produced that right
but if he's dead so is that i guess cars
tom hanks also produces all those like
cnn special events like the 80s the 90s
like those and he produces the rock and
roll hall of fame too there's a lot of
doo doo in here though to be honest
he's like you said he made a lot of
moves
not all winner i think things that he's
attached to as a producer are probably
listed in here as well
there's a lot of doo-doo here guys uh
yeah i guess it is working like his his
peaks works a lot or maybe higher than
anybody except maybe leo but
the lows are pretty low on this as well
so i don't know
oh i remember this film the circle
remember seeing ads for this 5.3 brutal
it looks like uh with 12 000 votes in
though
it's close between denzel and rdj but it
looks like denzel is is losing we love
you dance and leo is the one with the
least vote leo might actually be the the
big top dog he does not have a bad movie
he has to hang on he has to i'm going to
pull up his his uh
i'm calling he does not have a bad movie
at least one i've never said like all
that [ __ ] i mean he's done a lot of
movies
let's look at his films here
i wish it wasn't just like critters
three awesome into like just dating 20
year old models yeah the 20 year old
thing he's a little bit about team star
style well a little bit of a creep like
tom hanks has a family
yeah we like that for him and we like
how that turned out all right look let's
look at uh leonardo's cause this one
that's true family doesn't always work
out
i mean his family produces
it's not exactly utopia behind the
scenes you never know what you're gonna
get
wait what the [ __ ] is oh no not raiding
um
you gotta do the
people saying justice for denzel i know
i i agree with you people out there but
it's hard i mean
again i think all three
it it's tough
the [ __ ] am i looking at what are you
looking at
i have no idea
i sent an article from rolling stone oh
rotten tomatoes is a good call yeah
okay wait go ahead yeah there's a super
chat saying leo is a creepy day it's
teenagers i don't know if he dates
teenagers he does he does
i mean
i thought it's more keemstar stuff pull
up his uh dating history
i don't know but i agree that he's a
grape for
i know there's that there's that chart
that's kind of iconic here i just found
it
[Music]
here
yeah this is the way to do it highest
rated movies catch me if you can
excellent the departed
gilbert grape
cancelled that movie's cancelled
titanic i mean
django inception aviator
once upon a time in hollywood this [ __ ]
is like never ending slaps
the goat
so leo dated at an 18 year old when he
was 24. since then that's not the
youngest his girlfriends were was 20.
yeah but how old is he starting at 40
like 43 he was dating a 20 year old yeah
yeah i mean that's that's keemstar style
right but what the famous grow up
already that he does
yeah when they turn 26. 25 according to
this chart show me the chart let me put
it on it's on screen
oh okay
oh my god
wow data is beautiful
[Laughter]
he's 46 right now
so yeah he dated a teenager when he was
24 which you know is
this was in 1999. that's not great but
yeah but now he's 44 dating a 20 yeah
like i get that it's illegal he's not
doing anything illegal but it's just
gross well the fact that he always
breaks up with him at the same age
it's so gross
intentional or not it's uh
[Laughter]
i mean you would just think that as he
matured he would want the company of
someone more mature you would but it
just it seems like he just
i don't know
like i can't imagine spending my time
with peace and love i mean i don't know
without like a near the teenager
no
there's a maturity gap
especially for someone like leo who's
been around and seen and done so much
so denzel isn't a creep
is he a family man
yeah he's well well regardless
we're saving him do we do we lose his
son
if we lose denzel
why does denzel have a famous son yeah
john david washington
from uh black clans man great actor he
was the lead tenant as well
how do i see more movies of his i want
to see the whole discography
i had all of their stuff linked in the
dark
link to their wikipedia article with the
list of all their movies so he's married
with kids right
uh denzel let's see if he's still
married denzel why
ain't god get on me
why the [ __ ] can't i uh oh here okay
here i got it
denzel has been married to the same
woman since 1983. love that you guys
love points for that i agree you get
extra points make it work damn it
let me keep going departed titanic
django inception aviator once upon a
time in hollywood marvin's room
not familiar with that one
wolf of wall street the revenant
[Applause]
gangs of new york that was a good one
let's go down to the bottom i feel like
that's more interesting yeah sure
i sent an article from the rolling
stones where they rate his work critters
three has a
zero three yeah
where did you send an article from maybe
i said the rolling stones
what the [ __ ] is critters three what did
he do in this film
what did he do on criticism according to
wikipedia it was like one of his first
movies it was his first movie oh well it
was a direct direct video it's a low
budget that's nice
have you ever seen any of the critters
movies
i'm not part of the critter country
is this the first time for you in the
critters universe yeah i think i think
justin was trying to get us to watch it
dude the original critters and the
second one are
iconic
yeah but he he actually all of his
movies are pretty iconic it looks like
he doesn't make that many bad films
the man in the iron mask anyone watch
that that's a good movie
that's supposedly that is the worst that
is like ali's favorite movie
once a month well i think the people
have spoken denzel you're getting tossed
at the bin with peace and love peace
this is a serious message for denzel
washington
with peace and love
any movies with denzel after the 24th of
september is being tossed in the bin
thank you thank you thank you
and no objects to be looked at thank you
thank you thank you thank you
here's another dumb ass what about the
fact that he apparently saved the family
or something
sorry denzel washington
i don't know about that story from a
burning car on the freeway
i don't care what he's done he's been
tossed in the bin
thank you thank you tossed in the bin no
objects to be signed nothing
here's another dumbass uh debate oh
someone said just wanted to mention it
again my dad is 84 with only one kidney
oh god bless that's epic epic thank you
yeah i was worried that it might reduce
the lifespan but i was reading the
internet and it doesn't really seem like
like um
it does
you know even if he gets like kidney
damage and what kidney it's like
everyone's walking around with a spare
it's got to be one of the easiest organs
to get
and just with medicine and technology
right
i mean
there's buildings
yeah everybody's got a spare you're
right
yeah it's like the only organ you have a
spare of there's billions of them my
brother-in-law's studying human
regenerative biology like stem cell
research it's crazy what they're on the
cusp of creating oh being able
he could have one of mine i mean that's
what i was like well if he needs a
kidney i've got one i don't know if he
wants mine though i won't serve him very
well i think you have to be a match but
there's a highlight yeah right
if not me then who
people are
triggered they want to recount
oh then they don't want to throw denzel
out i don't i don't think they want to
throw him out
okay who cares kill denzel and robert
downey
kill him
no more thank you thank you so special
you're very special
all right listen here's another dumb
debate that was raging on twitter
billboard presents this theory is drake
in 2021 now as big as michael jackson or
the beatles wearing their peek no you
[ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ]
how dare you even put this forward well
i guess i know where you land on this i
didn't even know they caught i heard
them say michael jackson i didn't know
they even conjured the beatles how dare
you yeah most people focused on the
michael jackson i saw the michael
jackson yeah the beatles i'll [ __ ]
dare you
because i got this man's haircut bro
michael owned the rights to the beatles
i feel like that's one of the reasons it
was tossed out
and it was trending michael verse drake
right half the
catalog yeah he didn't own all of it
[Music]
how [ __ ] dare they no of course i
think it's stupid to compare
because like and i saw people say that
at the time of michael jackson he didn't
have what drake has today like social
media and
that's true screaming stuff and all
these things that's true but even even
all things considered equal michael
jackson was a cultural phenomenon that
took the world i don't even care about
drake like i mean i know i'm just one
person i'm sure there's plenty of people
that care about michael jackson but like
michael jackson was a cultural
phenomenon yeah the mania in the in the
early 80s for michael jackson is i mean
thriller is the best-selling album of
all time even to this day yes and by
like a lot actually and then to compare
it even to the beatles makes me want to
[ __ ] spit
i mean the beatles i mean nobody should
even compare themselves to the beatles
ever to go back to michael he did it
solo but he also did it with the jackson
five too they're right
i mean
i'm just the fact that they would even
conjure the beatles in the same sentence
as drake is to me repulsive it's bizarre
and it's [ __ ] disgusting and how dare
billboard i mean it's just it's sick
this is sick
well i think the thing with the beatles
is even if you you're not a beatles fan
you're like too young for you just not
for you or whatever
you know who's not a beatles fan
oh plenty no who in this room doesn't
love the beatles
you do you don't love them
i respect them i will always respect the
world
people i met people who don't like the
middle george no but i feel like people
that don't like the beatles are just
trying to be contrarian yeah they're
like it's too obvious they're like oh no
no no i respect them i believe
zach is actually making the point that i
was about to make is that
you know people can think they're
overrated or they don't like them or
whatever but just historically the the
impact that they had on popular music
absolutely is kind of unparalleled
really there hasn't been anybody that
changed man i'm surprised
of all people to raise their hands zach
i'm really surprised by that i i didn't
want to be the first person i think it
might be like
we got a second second i just don't know
enough i mean what i've heard i like but
i'm just not as familiar i've always
been more of a stones fan
oh come on
i'm gonna get [ __ ] but i believe me i
respect the work of the peoples
absolutely love you're also uh not in
favor of the beatles though yeah there's
a few brothers a few people in the chat
saying they're not fans the beatles are
garbage it's just somebody's trying to
catch a band in our chat right that's
too far that's too i mean people who say
the beatles are garbage have never
actually listened to their discography
and they're just being contrarian sorry
that's what it is because their music is
undisputed the best
it is the best yeah
classic rock when classic when coming at
classic rock i really like the beatles
the hard
the writing the music it's on a it's in
a league of its own i mean stop it well
what's your favorite beatles album
because they're all so they're all
[ __ ] like 10 out of 10 albums really
in your opinion rubber soul magic
mystery tour white album
every track on that album [ __ ] hit
hard
octopuses garden you like that one it's
not 10 out of 10.
i mean it's good there is some stickers
on that wait are you really going to
talk [ __ ] on magical mystery tour you i
don't think it's one of their stronger
albums i'm a white album guy i love
sergeant
pepper abby rose
revolver is one of my favorites that's
what i'm saying who's got the albums
they're all five stars they're all
perfect
no they don't zeppelin no they don't
yeah they do they do
okay who cares nobody cares the point is
the break is not the full on the hill
that's a good that can be tossed what
that can be tossed okay that's that's
something that i can't disagree with
that is a great song
okay regardless
drake nobody [ __ ] cares bye oh sorry
certified lover boy my ass
[Laughter]
bye bye i mean where the [ __ ] do i
really even start
i got hoes that are living in the dark
i'm impressed
[Laughter]
favorite beatles song go
you can't pick a favorite beatles song
really
you don't have there's not one that like
i love i honestly i love them too much
to pick one i really do
what's your favorite
i'd say strawberry fields i'll stop it
you're not a beatles fan it's not my
favorite
mine would probably be nowhere man
you can't pick one you can't you can't
pick your favorite children i think
that's probably my favorite that or uh
places i remember
people keep saying paul what is that i
don't know what do you want what is the
fall
they're just spamming poles
do you just do you like the beatles i
guess is that the poll
a lot of people are gonna say yes and i
hope everyone likes the noodles for
people and things
that came from before
i know i'll often stop and think about
them
in my
life
i love you more
[Laughter]
all right do you like the beatles yes or
no ask the community here we go dude i
can't tell my heart can't take it
my heart can't thank people saying no to
this
i i promise anyone saying no to this is
just they haven't listened enough well
what other band would you put next to
the beatles in europe nobody's next to
the beatles
nobody
[Music]
really they're in a stratosphere of
their own everyone else is a step down
again we can't the poll's not accurate
either way yeah
what is the results
so far about a third of our audience
does not like the beatles no they said
yes do you like the beatles oh a third
right right yeah i mean listen that's
okay i think that's pretty good
considering this is a band from the 60s
yeah
you know and true that's very good like
pretty much everybody
didn't grow up on them like our
parents so but like if you want to go
down i mean yeah all the classic rock
bands i would say
leads at blinn quinn the band queen is
[ __ ] amazing you're a big fan of the
band not the band but levon helm yeah i
love dylan's band i love the band yeah
they're great
love dylan there's a super chat dylan
yeah it says the beatles are just the
wiggles for adults
the wiggles what is that that that's
what i mean that means that they just
listen to their pop [ __ ] which is like
she loves you yeah yeah yeah yeah like i
get i get it that that's the that's what
you think about and that was the pop
[ __ ] they literally stopped touring
because the pop [ __ ] was so lame they
couldn't even hear themselves play and
they stopped doing shows live and went
to the [ __ ] they started dropping
acid in india and then went into the
studio and made the most psychedelic
[ __ ] insane [ __ ] you've ever heard so
when you say it's just the wiggles for
adults then i i know what you're saying
is that you don't understand their
discography you have no [ __ ] idea
what you're talking about okay do you
know why they did that do you know why
they switched yeah because because they
could they were sick of playing
he was like too popular right
yeah they heard the beach boys and brian
wilson was giving them a run for their
money
with pet sounds
well regardless the music they made in
the studio uh is that that's to me when
they came into their element so
you want to be listening to rubber soul
you want to listen to sergeant pepper
you want to listen to magical mystery
thor you know i i do love their poppy
[ __ ] but uh it's not it's that's not
what defines the beatles yeah lots of
people are agreeing with queen which i
queen
totally so good
[Music]
all right
thank you thank you peace and love
i think everyone don't does not care
about drake though from what i mean
like even the people that like drake
don't care about drake even the guy
that's a superman fell asleep while
livestreaming his new album
yeah here
you people say is drake as big as
michael jackson or the beatles
here let let me uh settle
that debate right here now as someone
links i think i just found it yeah i can
just throw it out here is drake's
biggest fan okay live streaming his new
album
because my top five is drake drink drink
drink
[Laughter]
that is the best
that's his drink
by the
way my top five is drink drink drink
drink
by the way i actually hold kendrick
lamar up there with the greats
i think he's one of the best musicians
that ever
to lived a butterfly inspired david
bowie's last record before he died
really yeah
you know that yeah kendrick lamar is one
of my favorites ever actually i put i
put him up there
i also really like biggie and tupac
but there the thing is
i mean biggie really only ever made one
album so it's hard to say
but
yeah kendrick's up there for sure i love
all of his music
i mean where the frick do i really even
start
such a nerd where the frick do i really
even start i got girls that are living
in the dark
i like drake i just don't think he
compares to those he's fine he's fine
yeah but you can't conjure his name up
it's happening
point that over at us stop
i'm just kidding i
like all right let's move on enough of
this
i think michael jackson's up there with
the greats too even though he's like a
[ __ ] p word big time
no debate
straight up
i got kids that are sleeping in my bed i
sent the parents on vacation
and he stayed with me privately for
seven days and ap says is there a reason
you're looking at me yes because no no
we're not doing we're not doing this no
we're not doing it we're not doing this
that that's michael jackson's version of
that i got kids that are sleeping in my
bed and here i set the paris all the way
to hawaii whoa look at that baby womp
now huge officially
i don't hang out with fat or ugly little
boys
only beautiful little models and no
girls either i disprove that
[Applause]
what because he hung out with one burn
victim like sorry bro
not buying it
and he sent me a burn victim i was like
what the [ __ ] dude
oh i saw a mention of our kelly where is
r kelly on the list
i mean yeah who can beat uh do you have
your passports
i got it here's michael jackson
do you have your lollipops
did your parents go vacation and trust
[Music]
don't you
[Music]
did you know
[Applause]
[Music]
still think i'm innocent
you know what i'm trying to enjoy my
weekend
i don't need no [ __ ] reddit
[ __ ] dms
[Laughter]
plenty of people even in this chat i'm
not saying anything i'm just watching
the chat don't worry
nobody could baby [ __ ] i'm we're all
just having a good time like what what
is that you're trying to show like
michael jackson pretty young
he's got his passport on
well actually i'm getting the last one
in five days okay okay
put up a poll i actually
because you're gonna [ __ ] need it
thank you keemstar i agree no i
genuinely didn't say i'm gonna say
anything i genuinely curious because to
me it's so obvious but i know there's a
lot of people out there that you know
think he's innocent somehow there's
someone in the chat said abuse the
cruise cries thank you cry baby your
mom's a cry baby there there seems to be
some
i'm sounds relieved to see
because sometimes you don't know when it
comes to the michael jackson discourse
online there's so many people that
support him that are so vocal that
um
you kind of lose sight but yeah
according to this poll 79 percent of
people think mj did it
the next the next poll let's be let's do
do you like h3h3
what are you saying
i'm saying these are your fans you get a
lot of simps
oh
i don't think so i think there's people
i mean there's 21 that said no
oh oh [ __ ] a fly litter just landed on
them
[Laughter]
oh my god that was awesome
so what do you want me to do go to
michael jackson is uh innocent uh form
and take a poll there dominance and do
anything
i'm curious
how many people here watch housewives of
beverly oh jesus
you know howard always talks about it
but i've never watched yet
i have seen it i used to spend a lot of
time in sixth grade on fridays
watching it
all right so it's not as fun to debate
but
we should do a paul who thinks erica
knew
oh come on everybody thanks erica now
everybody you could do the ball people
didn't know yeah okay so eric one of the
housewives is married to the super rich
super prominent lawyer he was like the
biggest lawyer and he he was famous for
doing these
massive
uh
how do you call the suits we have all
those people
uh class class action lawsuit
yeah and he would uh represent the
victims and win these like massive
hundred million dollar
settlements
and so it and so
she and him i have this huge [ __ ]
life massive life living large large
large wait real quick the question is do
you think erica knew yeah yeah and is it
erica with a k yeah i see people saying
that erica jane and so what what we're
getting to is her husband
it just came out like a year or two ago
this huge story broke
that her husband has been
stealing
tons of millions of dollars from victims
from
burn victims
pregnancy yeah
like the worst thing and like uh people
who survived the airplane crash
yeah like just the worst type of people
yeah and this guy was already making a
lot of money so he was basically never
paying them out their settlement and
there's phone calls of him being like
hey i need to hold you you let me hold
your money i'll invest it for you stuff
like that and he was just spending it
and spending it on erica nice and the
truth the crazy thing is that she's been
on this show while it's happening just
flaunting her money like crazy like
that's all she does and she would she
would talk about how she spends like 40k
a month just on glam squad she has a
glam squad follower everywhere to do her
hairs and nails and makeup and stuff and
she has the worst part about this girl
she's like in her 40s talentless as it
gets and she's trying to become a pop
star yeah he's funding her whole
ambitions to be a pop star and she's
[ __ ] horrible and they're spending
like probably tens of millions of
dollars every year to feed her delusion
and it's all on the show and now all of
a sudden it comes out that this is all
ill-gotten money stolen from horrible
victims wow and um now she's being
investigated and it's all happening on
the show and it's so [ __ ] spicy and
the thing is that she
mysteriously
divorced him like right before the story
broke
they were married for 15 years
she divorced him right before the story
broke and then investigators found out
that right before the divorce he sent
her 20 million in cash
trying to
stash it away
and so she's being like interested
blah blah blah and everyone's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] knew and she might be going
to jail and she's all well the
housewives are kind of annoying though
because they're not saying that to her
face even though they're all thinking it
except
saturn
and then they're they're throwing her
under the bus and then they're like oh
we didn't throw you under the bus we're
doing it for you it's amazing the drama
is amazing
i can't imagine a reality show having
juicier drama i mean it's incredible
what's the poll say
so
i put an option um
i haven't seen the show because i didn't
want to have people voting when they
haven't but uh out of the people that
have seen the show the yes is
overwhelmingly amazing that three
percent say no imagine being a stanford
erica jane
let me show you a picture of her just so
you can see how annoying she is
actually let me show you one of her
performances even better
erica jane
performance bro you
guys yes tim sutton everyone in the chat
i'm definitely team saturn and garcelle
has been the only
voices of reason so here is
here is erica j is that her husband what
is it
so this is her performance and i mean
this is just the road to nowhere dude
she has no time none
good this is a nightmare
[Applause]
can you turn it up i can't even hear it
[Applause]
yeah okay
yeah it's just
it's bad epic yeah it's bad
so there you have it
uh there's a really good documentary
about
uh tom and erica from the victims
perspective if anyone hasn't seen it you
should watch it it's on hulu
yeah the housewife and the hustler it's
good it's really good i mean you
you really see how
those victims really got screwed by him
yeah that's great this dude they're they
talk a lot by this one guy this burn
victim yeah he won like nearly 10
million dollars
but he has tons of medical bills he
can't work he can't do anything so he
needs that money yeah
and [ __ ] tom stole it all he was like
erica could go do her he spent it all on
erica yeah he would basically tell him
oh i'm just doing it for you so you
don't irresponsibly waste the money or
something like that meanwhile he's
spending forty thousand dollars a day on
glam
listen burn victim i got an expensive
wife here
wait he was the lawyer for the aaron
brockovich thing yes holy [ __ ] yeah he's
a big he's really famous and like
like the biggest work in democratic
party politics oh what a surprise
probably flew on epstein's airplane a
few times too you know what i mean
so this is real housewives of beverly
hills yeah yeah yeah and actually on
this documentary ela talked about they
have record phone recordings of him
talking to them and it's very chilly how
he lies
and just i mean this is high level
crimes that's wild i'll have to look
into this i'm telling you this
housewives is unfucking beatable wow
jesus yeah
it's awesome
it's great it's crazy that she's
choosing to be on the show but she's not
desperate i think she needs the money
she has nothing else going on they froze
all of her assets right of course but
it's like the whole season is just about
her but she's crying and playing the
victim and it's so upsetting and she had
no idea and it's like i just i don't
like that i it never seems like not even
once it that she's crying over like what
he actually did to the victims like it's
always just about how poor erica
everyone is calling her a liar
and how she's not getting any money hey
dude it's so good
so good
you guys want to talk about the mario
movie because this is pretty amazing
yeah mario movies
so they've been working on a nintendo's
feature-length animated mario movie
and they announced the cast and it is
[ __ ] actually i'd like to watch
donkey
if we can oh i want to watch donkey his
version of the reaction
the cast reveal is so insane did you see
it no it doesn't make any sense to
people that they cast it's just such a
[ __ ] show
i'm friends with someone on the inside i
don't want to say who it is but
he was working on the movie
and uh he he quit because it turned into
such a [ __ ] show
it's in the uh and and in the discord
now we all know exactly what he meant
nobody can do it better than donkey well
here's duncan reacting to the livestream
who will be voicing mario and his
friends in the movie
first of course the [ __ ]
is playing mario
chris brown
mario
the italian plumber it's samia mario
hi guys i mean what the [ __ ] is this
and it keeps getting crazier and crazier
we will be played by chris pratt
he's so cool
he's so cool
mario's little brother what the [ __ ]
i'm excited for you to see this timothy
he's so funny on screen
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
that doesn't make any sense
that actually is one of the only like he
can actually like voice act and do
voices and stuff
yeah but he but he can voice act okay
but it's the people like seth rogen seth
rogen cannot sound like anybody but seth
rogen and he's going to be donkey kong
as donkey kong
yeah and i mean chris pratt i know he
he's done some voices
is he going to do is this italian
appropriation
this is cultural appropriation
anti-italian discrimination this is
[ __ ] racist against the italians
oh no
mr mario
i know it was you
for you to cast the chris pratt that's
an authentic italian
i know it was your christmas
ashamed so cool this is so cool
[Music]
now that's an italian it's so cool
are we just dropping the italian stick i
i have to assume so
otherwise it would really be like a
really racist italian accent the whole
time he's so cool okay we should take a
vote on the on the on the this movie is
going to be horrible horrible or
vulnerable i mean i'm talking so we said
this about the sonic movie and it came
back to bite us this one's gonna be
under fifty percent
maybe this is gonna be like so bad that
it's good that everyone loves it
i don't think so they tried too hard
with the actors it's like when you when
you see a movie invest that much on cast
you know it sucks
well it's that's become
i don't know
all big animated movies are doing this
now they don't use voice actors they
just use
you know big names uh as part of the
marketing i guess
i mean i i don't really have a problem
with jack black as brow bowser no i
don't like he'll be funny i'm sure
the seth rogen is donkey kong is
actually
everybody's focusing on the chris pratt
but that's the one that actually gets me
the most because like he's his voice is
so distinct he can't sound
and i like seth rogen a lot but he's so
cool
i for me the chris pratt is the worst
there's like there's a lot of people in
the chat that think it's gonna be good
nope
no chance no [ __ ] chance
hi it's me chris pratt he's so cool
i think i think it might be good too
based on what
the cast chris pratt is so cool
i mean it speaks for itself
okay
well before you remember the 1993 mario
movie
one of the worst films ever
4.1 definitely
definitely so bad it's good in my
opinion yeah but at least here oh god
it's been so long
i mean i was so young i didn't have a
problem with it at the time
oh this is copyright music
do you know about this hila
no they made a live action mario bros
and it is one of the weirdest movies
ever made
for real what the [ __ ]
no i've never seen this it's pretty wild
it's like dystopian sci-fi for some
reason uh
what does that have to do with mario
there's a lot that doesn't have anything
to do with mario in this movie it blows
my mind that dennis hopper's in it it
just yeah dennis hopper is
his bowser that's yoshi the like
actual dinosaur
kind of looks epic it does look kind of
amazing like they're ballsy i mean a
ballsy uh
i don't know man
not a good he's so cool
what is this baby
i would just read it first um i'll dirty
dom put out a new vid
should we watch it
i'm watching it right now i'll put it on
what the [ __ ] do i care
oh he's talking about the hannah
situation
now
how long has it been
exposing the truth shut up you freaked
out
let's watch this
[Music]
dude he is such a creep like we watched
his tick tock how he was pretending to
be with you yeah right he's such a creep
those are weird
also he already apologized once for like
essaying a girl at like
what was it called
vidcon a while ago yeah it's like bro
you don't have any ground to stand on
but okay let's listen to this just
all of this to uh
to be with my parents to be with my
family and uh to process
all the information
now i'm ready to talk i was raised by my
parents to be
a good person i don't care
yeah i don't care about how you were
raised tell me what happened dude
trying to [ __ ] uh taint the jury pool
and be honest and
i
i don't think i've been honest with you
guys i think
a lot of times i'm desensitized to stuff
i think a lot of times i act on impulse
and
i i needed to take some time to really
go through everything and analyze myself
and
you know show you show you guys who i
really am i haven't done a good job of
separating dirty dom the crazy party
animal you know
guy that hooks up with a bunch of girls
and me dominicus the guy that
hangs off my friends goes to the beach
reads books he goes to the beach
such a [ __ ] downer dude
people are pointing out his hairline i
mean listen i wasn't gonna go there
yeah not the time i wasn't gonna go
there people in chat are talking about
his hairline
i mean nothing needs to be said i mean
come on
ian look at my hairline
look at his hairline
i mean enough i don't nothing needs to
be said
look at my hairline
thank you
weird of him to
say like dirty dom the guy who hooks up
with all these girls when he's kind of
responding to all of these allegations
and he's like i hook up with a lot of
girls yeah it's like also that's you
yeah that's like cool you go to the
beach but you also hook up in your alter
ego you're also [ __ ] the girls yeah
he's like no no no you don't understand
dom just goes to the beach so chill
hang on
oh they know
all right let's continue
hangs off my little brother mom oh he
hangs out with his little brother and
mom he's so [ __ ] cool different than
i thought he was
um
dirty dom was someone i created
when i moved up here to l.a
i
i didn't smoke i didn't
hook up with girls i didn't i didn't
drink in high school and
i i was never one of the cool kids so
when i moved out here to
a chance to l.a
myself and be who i wanted to be i just
wanted to be accepted by my peers you
know
by
other people around me by girls maybe
someone else wants to watch and tell us
if there's anything good now let's talk
about what happened no you are yeah i
don't know
are you interested what do you guys
think
i'm not sure i didn't get far enough
i'm people really want the channel five
oh the chat video yeah
okay
let me let me watch another minute see
where it goes where it's going
okay spend the night of those
allegations there he goes right into it
also some of the stuff that i'm gonna be
talking about is um
it's uh
it's gonna be pretty serious and it
might trigger some survivors we came up
with the idea to do this five-sum bit
um
so i put out a instagram post saying hey
girls come over we need you know 10
girls at the apartment a bunch of girls
the more the better later that night
hannah and
i think like five of her friends show up
and then
vlog squad there's me
there's nick there's jeff
todd
david
jason
and trisha the girls show up
we start hanging out
a little bit later todd and jeff leave
and then they come back
we all start drinking with the girls
where'd they go i wonder where'd they
leave and come back with it's almost
like they went and bought alcohol and
came back huh
so weird that they left and came back
why would they do that why would you
leave and then come back during a party
such an odd [ __ ] coincidence
i'm talking to hannah and a couple of
her friends
and the rest of the guys were talking to
the other girls after a little bit me
and hannah and her friend go to my room
to hook up
we keep drinking and we start having sex
together while we're having sex
david
nick todd and jeff are peeking inside
the room everyone that looked inside the
room didn't
say that there was anything wrong or
didn't feel any type of way
and
didn't bring anything up after the girls
and me finished having sex i was laying
on the bed with hannah and her friend
at this time no i'm just curious was it
him or dirty dom to had sex with them
we were all talking and hannah
falls asleep right she was drinking a
little bit more than the other girl so i
just continue to talk to the other girl
for a little bit after we're done
talking and we're ready to go you know
meet up with the rest of the vlog don't
you see just in his story him saying she
was drunk enough to pat's out in the
stranger's bed you have to be so [ __ ]
drunk to just straight up pass out like
that
like dude come on bro it's kind of just
validating our story swat on the girls
we wake hannah up uh her friend helps
put on her clothes and helps her get
dressed
and we walk out to meet them helps her
get dressed yeah
dude
he's admitting that she's blackout
why would she need help getting dressed
and putting on her clothes dude
oh my god he's confessing
the rest of her friends and vlog squad i
stay in the apartment and the girls
hannah
and
todd jeff nick and david
end up uh letting the girls out the next
day
letting the girls out what were they
trapped
or did they have to be walked out
because they were so drunk letting the
girls out were they being forced against
their will to stay there david hits me
up to finish the ending of the video
where i'm like sweating and dripping and
sweat and then brandon's there and alex
is there and they weren't there the
previous night but they were there
to finish that scene so
that happens the next day i also get a
few texts from hannah the one that
basically just the uh
story we already know
what what truth is he's confessing
actually which is really interesting
yeah
he's verifying everything yeah do you
think that's what he's trying to do
maybe maybe he is because so far he's
kind of verifying everything
but he's he was like we went into the
room we had sex yeah like he was he was
very nonchalant about he's like trying
to make it sound like
yeah
i think he's trying to split the blame
more like he's saying you know they all
came in the room they didn't see
anything wrong with it yeah well he's
right
but they're also guilty and the way that
they've tried to squirm out of
accountability is [ __ ] up because he's
right they were there and they were
peeking in and they all saw and that
this girl was blackout drunk and so i
don't know i think he's trying to snitch
on them all because his life is ruined
and he thinks that they have equal blame
i mean he i mean you were the one in the
room bro let's be honest but they also
were there
and by the way he even tries to he
literally said jeff left the party and
came back he's saying they went and
bought alcohol there was no reason for
him to include that detail other than
for him to say they went and bought
alcohol without actually straight up
saying it
bro he's straight snitching on everyone
and here's what she said hi dom
it's hannah just woke up
thank you so much for having me over i
know i was very drunk but i was having a
blast and hope you did too
also anything at your discretion is okay
for the vlog just maybe not anything
that a future employer could use against
me he he
tell your friends to go
for it with the content he has and then
i said
hi glad you're okay i just woke up too
glad you're okay
i mean he was drunk yeah i mean he he
must have been worried about her to say
i'm glad you're okay
you know but she explained this she had
just woken up she was still drunk and
like not understanding yeah and she
explained
but but for him to say i'm glad you're
okay he must that implies he was worried
about her to lmao i had fun we should
hang out again then she says
hope you slept well i'm down i still
want to paint your nails i said ha ha
okay let's do it
you won't [ __ ] it up promise and she
says pinky swear i say okay you free
later this week and she said you should
be reading or the weekend smiley face i
say okay and then later in the week she
texts me what's the rest of your week
looking like i say working on different
stuff
what you doing tonight she says so much
work i said shaking my head now i have
to paint my nails myself you let me down
she says haha don't worry you'll be
blessed with my nail work one day the
reason we were talking about nails was
because
did she also release these texts i think
she released part of it but not all of
them that's so violating
right
i don't see what's the point this is not
like disproving what she said she showed
the first part where she was like where
she's like hey
i sent this text to him okay but i was
still drunk and not really understanding
the situation
yeah she said her friend had to tell her
like twice
what happened
and i know because the first time she
was still so
hungover she didn't even yeah
yeah so this was like the very next
morning i guess yeah she explained this
now sometimes and i asked her to help me
paint them because i always screw them
up when i do them myself cool this was
in november and then a few months later
in february i get a text from hannah
basically saying that you know she wants
to have the video taken down um she
doesn't like it being up
so yeah
we saw the text she's saying i felt
violated
i felt like i remember that one yeah the
text she sent him was like basically i
feel like you essayed me and i don't
want that video up but i feel violated i
like how damn plays it yeah i think
it sounds like he's trying to
romanticize their relationship a little
bit he's like yeah i wanted to
do my nails and she was going to help me
with yeah i was like nobody can okay
he's doing the typical victim blaming
where it's like oh victim shaming where
it's like she wanted it um she messaged
me the next day like she had fun because
she hadn't processed her trauma yet
doesn't mean anything but it's funny
because he's self-reporting in so many
other ways
that he doesn't realize i guess i take
screenshots of the conversation i had
with her the whole conversation and i
sent it to david and he tells me how to
reply to hannah i have someone here that
was there that day that david received
those texts for me and basically told me
how to reply hi guys this is [ __ ]
juicy
wait do you know who that is he's
calling out david oh yeah well we all
knew that but it's interesting he says
david knows that she asked to take the
video down because she felt like she was
essayed
which we all knew about here i don't
know who this girl is about let's watch
um
my name is cassandra and i met david
in 2017. i used to work in a pr agency
doing
what
what what just emotional
keep playing i just
wait let me go back a little bit because
i don't know 2017 i used to work in a pr
agency
doing
okay
okay
don't touch her
it's good you're fine
it's fine
i used to um
work with the blog squad and david
um
i always went an extra mile for david
because i believed in him and i thought
he was a good person
let's just just take a second
david wouldn't give cars
david wasn't philanthropic at all
he was just like this guy that would and
this is a quote from his manager
that would make his friends drink pee
like not even use
not a jerk
what the [ __ ] is happening right now
he would make his friends drink pee i'm
sorry let me back this up this guy that
would and this is a quote from his
manager
that would make his friends drink pee
like not even his not a jerk
in february
this is rough
2019 just peed in my basement
david received the text from
dom
and
when david received the text from dom
david did not want to take the video
down in the room it was jason nally and
david i decided to contact a friend of
mine that
is a lawyer
and she advised that the video
like my instant reaction was to take the
video down we
drafted different versions of what
should be the response to hannah and one
of the things i was constantly
mentioning was that
dom maybe raped a girl and that they
should contact a lawyer
and that they should have removed
themselves
to relate to dom because of that
situation dude this is so weird like dom
is sitting right next to her and she's
like this is so insane this is intense
bro she's saying he are wearing a girl
right next to him
so is he not denying i don't know this
is this is a lot this is kind of a big
deal this video yeah i think he's just
trying to take everyone with him at this
point yeah
this is a big deal this is a big [ __ ]
deal this video right here
hang on i go back i miss a word of this
raped a girl does tr imagine trisha
right now trying not to make a video
about this
trisha just disavowed making any drama
videos
this is a true test for her
yeah i thought there's no waitress it
doesn't make a video about this
and that they should contact their
lawyer
and that they should have removed
themselves
to relate to dom because of that
situation
and that don should have handled the
situation with david i will be
discussing more things moving forward uh
the reason that led us to this video is
because i interviewed don this is
something that's very close to my heart
as of in the last few months there's a
lot of things that have come
into my attention i want to thank cass
for getting on here you know i know it's
um
it's tough to you know talk about stuff
like this i appreciate you giving your
input i um
i [ __ ] up
so
yeah i mean it's what we suspect it
happened but it's
good that they're both saying is that
this girl said hey take this video down
i was r-worded and david said no i want
to take it down
[ __ ] i'm incredible
man i uh
i thought that by us filming this video
it was just another fun
stupid vlog
and that everything would be fine and
nobody was harmed and
i was wrong it
it impacted these girls
and it's gonna it's gonna follow them
for their whole life and
i
i know what we did that night wasn't
right i know i know
we shouldn't have we shouldn't have
filmed that video and we shouldn't have
put you guys in that position and
maybe you felt like you were there
am i crazy do i hear someone talking
is there a video playing
who's playing a video
maybe
i hear i hear a video playing
now it's stopped
did you hear that i did hear it who's
playing a video
one of y'all it stopped
somebody's not owning [ __ ] right now
anyway
what
i'm literally checking everything it's
not me
i literally have two pairs of headphones
just to be no it sounds like it was
coming through headphones really loud
yeah that's what it sounded like yeah
hey someone
switched
mute speech mute switch
not on
[Music]
oh i think i got fly
excrement in my eye
and and and you're going to be in a
video that's supposed to be fun and
it turned out being not fun it turned
out
being humiliating and degrading
someone said in the chat someone was
making a video hey cameo
[Laughter]
someone's making a cameo is that what's
going on
embarrassing
and
the last thing i wanted was
for you guys to feel like
um
like we're using you i am
i want to say i'm sorry to hannah and to
her friends for putting them in this
position and for not
considering their feelings and for not
taking them seriously and for um
making a mockery and a joke out of them
with this video i understand that it's
gonna take time for you guys to heal the
last thing i want is for you guys to
feel envy or feel hatred towards
yourselves for you know
being in this video because it is our
fault the responsibility falls on us as
content creators to
make sure you have thoughts olivia
i just don't like it
i'm not sure what is he trying to say
he's playing david yeah but he's not
because he wasn't admitting it's a moral
failure it's not a failure as a content
creator yeah
that's why because he keeps trying to
direct it towards david because he's
like he and i think in his mind he
resents david because he's like if he
never uploaded this video like and he's
like we should have never uploaded it
and if we did never upload upload it
none of this would have ever happened
and he's saying it or or maybe even if
david would have removed the video when
she asked you know like david had so
many opportunities
and dom who's guilty regardless of if
the video was uploaded or not
is just thinking like he could have been
saved this public humiliation
yeah because he's keep saying we
because it was like you know he's he's
including david sure that whoever we're
filming or however we're putting in our
videos is comfortable and knows
what they're getting into and we didn't
do that we just posted this video
because we thought that it would give us
more money and more clout and um
we
yeah we we [ __ ] we [ __ ] up i think
there needs to be some type of way for
youtubers and anyone else in the social
media space to
do things the right way and i uh i don't
know again it's like dude you are worded
someone i don't know what that has to do
with
and also you don't have to be you don't
need [ __ ] lessons to know not to
upload a video where girls blackout
drunk being used like that like i'm
sorry david it's not rocket science
i i don't i don't know the answer i wish
i i wish i did growing up i uh another
[ __ ] flaw i had all guy friends i
never really had you know a lot of
female peers
you know besides my mom and and and my
aunt
um
so i never really got that
female perspective on stuff i understand
it's it's uh
it's a scary world out there
for women you know even walking down the
street at night as a girl
it's completely different than walking
down the street as a guy it's that type
of perspective that you get when you
have those conversations when you talk
to girls when you shut the [ __ ] up
dumb ass i'm weird
interesting though i think i don't know
if you think that's gonna affect david
it should i mean [ __ ] david bro
[ __ ] him for uploading that video and
then not taking it down i mean what a
piece of [ __ ] dude
i gotta pee so bad
how long we've been going dan
uh two hours and 25 minutes just about
it's me you mario
it's chris pratt i'm here to play your
mario it's great splat everybody
he's so cool
and here's my brother uh
uh
uh charlie day hey it's me luigi come on
guys
good charlie day impression
so everybody's asking if you're going to
watch the channel 5 video oh sure yeah
let's watch that i knew there was
something else i have to pee first
though so maybe you guys want to read
some donors or something
oh yeah i want to see that i forgot
a weird shift shift gears back into that
but uh
here let me do that real fast
he's so cool okay so actually we cast
our own um
we did our own casting for mario because
we weren't happy
so we did uh james charles says boo the
ghost
that's a perfect that's spot on
it's a little spook magook
we did keemstar as a wario of course
spot on
you know why wario wears that hat
hairline
we did phase blanks as waluigi very good
actually that's spot on blanks
as flutter cute
beautiful
some seemed appropriate absolutely gary
klein as king bob
perfect
perfection now here's oh love as womp
the one that falls because like the bar
love that
congratulations love that's a big thank
you thank you big moment for you a big
get
oh ian slater as lakitu
yeah we had to look up what his name was
the guy who throws shells from the cloud
that's right
i'll take it cute
sam of course as toadette
strangely appropriate congratulations
[Music]
oh olivia big roll here as rosalina
who apparently is what like dollar store
peach who's rosalina no
i've been told that she's more popular
than peach even amongst the uh the mario
stans if you will oh really well there
you go congratulations she's like the
cool peach thank you i'm flattered
we have cam as
toadsworth
i didn't know toadsworth was a character
the daily truth but
oh almost
toadsworth cameron congrats
jason nash making happiness
as iggy cooper
kind of got that going on there
a b as larry koopa these are these are
like very secondary characters
oh these are the the these are the
bowser juniors these are all
bowser's uh you know the blue hair kids
big eyes i kind of see you now
oh right
you look more like him today
zach as uh
the infamous
ludwig koopa
everybody
i have no idea who the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dan has a cameo
nice
fantastic
alfredo
uh cast as pucci
we love that for him
and myself as the one and only goomba
very excited lucky goomba roll
and
[Laughter]
there you go
you know something interesting we were
discussing the other day is what was our
first nintendo system and olivia's first
was a wii
yeah oh my god that made us feel really
old yeah yeah pretty old wii sports
makes even me feel old
[Laughter]
and i didn't have any
i think i was super nintendo i think i
don't think there's time
um
a bunch of donations just disappeared do
you guys have i don't know
i know yes we do hold on one sec
uh
lisa
uh
suarez donated 25 said queen ela please
please please
make teddy fresh car air fresheners that
look like the tf flags oh that's kind of
a cute okay okay
you know what you're not the first to
say it i wasn't a fan of the idea
but because of you
i will change my mind on that really
you already had it i wasn't a fan of the
idea but
a lot of people said that it's kind of
got yeah i could see it it's got the
right vibe it's the right size
um
let's see here i just opened up the
the full
list uh five dollars said his hairline
blows i'm assuming that was about dirty
dom
uh yep
as a side note someone said he has that
majin vegeta hairline i agree
oh yeah okay
uh
mega awesome nerd one of our mods
donated twenty dollars dude we're
supposed to pay you
donate 20 as a mario simp i'm so
god damn pissed baffled laughing and
bummed all at the same time
uh
charles martinei
i believe is how you pronounce that got
so done dirty oh that's the guy who does
the mario voice normally the it's a me
uh got so done dirty rather than casting
someone remotely fits they choose plain
ass chris pratt [ __ ] chris pratt he's
[ __ ] mad dude they haven't announced
who he's playing right the original
mario
uh he is like supposed to be involved in
somehow it's probably a cameo doing a
consulting why didn't someone just say
keep olivia away from kim star
because of her age because she's
probably good
yeah okay i was like what i saw someone
say that i'm 18 i'm 22 years old
[Applause]
uh
watch squid game on netflix you'd be
you won't be disappointed zack has been
raving about that
love uh so that's like his favorite show
he's ever seen it's one it's one of the
greatest things i've ever seen too all
right i'm always looking for stuff to
watch so good highly recommend haley
davis donate five dollars with peace and
love i come before you again to request
the viewing of channel five chet hanks
interview big ups well guess what
you're about to get what you asked for
uh somebody donated five sgds anybody
know what an sgd is what currency that
is i will find out they said a b
we love you oh wow
thank you i love you guys appreciate you
uh austin m said uh donated five dollars
said please type in r kelly net worth
huh
okay
okay
that was a singapore dollar by the way
oh uh what is art kelly's net worth
negative two million dollars
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and another five dollars please react to
channel five chet hanksvid all right
people are happy
all right
there were a couple more wishing us
sending us prayers and wishing us all
the
healthy and nice stuff with the
pregnancy so thank you i feel much
better since the yeah actually
and since the messages too yeah
like i said we're gonna go
for another scan in four weeks right
you see
how the stomach and everything's
developed i think he said in a month
yeah
i don't know
okay i wonder if we can do it sooner
than a month
maybe two weeks
also somebody said y'all should react to
kylene's eviction from big brother last
night reality tv gold
sure let's do it all
was that a close-up on your
i missed it
i gotta say
the slim jim
the skin is too solid
gross it's like solid disgusting but the
the lighter
no i mean i didn't light this one up
but i'm saying i didn't put a crack on
this one
so you think so you think the lighter
thing like does something that genuinely
makes it better
i don't know if it makes it better i
don't think anything could make this
better we got a super chip saying dan is
unappreciated also wish ethan and
hillary
appreciate it i feel like i appreciate
it
very appreciated
come on i feel like i'm appreciated at
an appropriate level i but i do
appreciate you saying yeah yeah
right
dan is the app
the h3 universe exactly dan how old is
the world on it
all right let's watch this chat man
um
regarding baby names i we have a few but
i don't i don't think i will share it
until
until there's a baby already started oh
never mind no i
ethan could you check the discord before
you play this just
just a little note
all right oh
it's the photo
i think well that's in the video that's
in the video so oh you make the call on
that sir what do you think about this
healer you think that's gonna get me
dinked
just the thing is just go watch the
video honestly it's a good video he's
looking like abs tick-tock feet
abe sent me a photo of chat in front of
some
large beautied uh
queens queens yes whoa by the way in
this video it's funny he says
he defines white boy summer yeah as
being about worshiping black women it's
for white guys that want to worship
black women that would i didn't
understand white boy summer like that
but it's specifically about fetishizing
black women so there you have it
i didn't know that about it
either that is bizarre the name is a
little misleading if i'm being honest
yeah he threw that in there and i was
like wow okay i didn't know that that
what this was all about
he goes how long have you been into
black chicks he goes as long as i can
remember really
how interesting this is
okay just tell me when the ass shot's
coming up baby what time does it appear
i'm looking right now
there's a lot of like quick b-roll
that's what i'm afraid of but at 6 43 is
where that's from okay i was hooking up
with this chick one day she was on the
phone with her family in jamaica and she
was really in the middle of a heated
conversation idea what the [ __ ] she was
saying and her friend said give me a
pick nina with me
i'm like wow wow so wait break that down
so she and so then i just started she
started breaking down a lot i'm like how
do you say this john no star how do you
say that up like seven
she was just telling me how to say
different [ __ ] so i got for like a week
like i was really on a jamaican tip and
that just happened to be the week of the
golden globes
a little bit yeah
i turned my phone on and the video had
gone totally viral yeah that's what you
did bro guys
i am shook and frankly
hella confused we got the youth then
where are the kingstown it's just
like why that's i just don't get why uh
appropriation that's fair that's a good
one i had jamaicans blowing up my
instagram the respect general rea become
the island you know what i mean the
jamaica jamaican people showed me the
most love every jamaican on the island
was stopping by his instagram to
congratulate him
check them off
hands down but then you got all these
social justice warriors in america
saying that i'm a [ __ ] villain how do
you feel about the idea of cultural
appropriation overall
again i don't think he's a villain i
think he's a goon yeah
angry
look dude of course people are gonna
make fun of you what do you think
i don't [ __ ] know dude
if i'm interested in [ __ ]
bull fighting i can fly to spain and go
watch a bull fight and if i want to go
talk to a matador and say hey bro can
you teach me how to [ __ ] fight the
girls and he's like hell yeah bro here
put this on he's stoked that i'm stoked
right some [ __ ] out there is gonna is
gonna say i'm [ __ ] up because i'm
culturally appropriating the matador
culture but but but i'm not even like
mad though because all these haters
they're on the way out dude there's more
people that [ __ ] with what the [ __ ] i'm
saying then there's people that are
angry about what the [ __ ] y'all talking
about and that's a [ __ ] fact
big reminder this isn't the man that
threatened to fight me in the dms
the whole island that man just don't do
that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what was this
he says don't do that make up your mind
chat
can they do it or not
yeah i'll go back for you i'm saying
that there's people that are angry about
what the [ __ ] y'all talking about and
that's a [ __ ] fact
big up the whole island then man just
don't do that
don't even do that why not you just need
to practice before you go on like a
a stage like that big big up to you with
them no no
i don't understand
say it with passion bro become the youth
pick up the youth
i think we almost sounded the same
this is starting to
[Music]
with stress callahan
so what was it like for you growing up
as a
the son of a prominent celebrity and it
was really kind of like a double-edged
sword
people assume and i just lived this life
like super privileged life like richie
rich you know what i mean and that just
wasn't the case
and it was actually the opposite damn
i got these [ __ ]
damn i'm sure it's the opposite
dude probably went to like the nicest
private school in l.a
look they never [ __ ] gave me an
allowance i don't know if i'm the
brokest rich kid or the richest broke
kid i love my my mom and dad a lot but
it was kind of inevitable that i
rebelled because they had me like on a
really short leash they're like really
like goody goody square you know boy
scout eagle scout scouts honor type
people you know what i mean that was
never my vibe for example like when i
got caught smoking weed right my mom was
out in absolute hysterics oh my god you
know i mean like it was it was bad
that's pretty funny i got sent away to
the [ __ ] um wilderness program when i
was 17. i'm in my life in the morning
the lights flip on there's two huge
dudes in my room bodybuilder looking
like bouncer types bald heads they're
like you're coming with us we can do
this the easier the hard way this i
actually feel bad for me
i don't understand parents to do that i
don't either it's so that sounds [ __ ]
cool
it sounds really cool dude any kid i
know that actually did this [ __ ] is the
most [ __ ] up people
i don't think we even have stuff like
that in israel
i've never i mean it's insane but
and just the idea of it sounds so cool
it's like that dr phil style
yeah i'm surprised tom stooped to that
level what happened to my cousin
same thing did it [ __ ] him up her yeah
she's uh
she's pretty out there it's pretty sad
it doesn't help it makes things way
worse yeah when your own parents betray
your trust yeah and basically have you
kidnapped yeah it's [ __ ] up the same
thing like two people went in a room it
should be illegal to be honest like that
yeah to me just just disgusting
like nobody ever comes back from
kidnapping camp and be like hello father
and mother i'm on the straight path i've
decided to get straight a's and go to
college and become a doctor
that's [ __ ]
and they just you know put me in the
back but he's right it's like usually
it's these parents that don't it's like
yeah i smoked a weed it's like and now
you're gonna have me kidnapped it's like
okay kids smoke weed it happens
don't be such a [ __ ] yeah so i feel
bad for chat actually yeah in in this
case
[Applause]
don't do that
i'm just doing what
he was doing in the video oh okay
shout out to the island man pick up at
them you
oh someone said that paris hilton was
abused in the
facility oh paris went to boot camp
uh yeah that's what her documentary was
about kidnap camp yeah she went to a
like reform school or something and she
was
uh really
seriously abused and a bunch of other
girls came out too
i don't know that would be illegal it
really should
i mean i guess it was in style back then
for some reason because it was on all
the talk shows like there's no
i i bet there's no study that would back
it up oh well bad baby was also like i
went to the camp and i got abused dr
phil
yeah the ranch yeah sorry about it i'm
not sending my kids to any [ __ ] ranch
huh where's the fly i want it on it no
way push the button
that's so awesome when they land on the
fly thing
you idiot fly you i hate it it's like
what else are you gonna do
what an idiot he landed on the fly trap
idiot
yeah please don't ever send your kids to
a ranch how about just talk to them deal
with your [ __ ] everyone is saying her
documentary is really good really
is it new
it was like last year
i think like september 20th or something
where is it it's youtube oh i was just
straight to you or i watched it on
youtube okay
yeah it's a youtube doc oh like a
youtube premium thing or just her uh
independent thing um this article just
calls it a youtube documentary let me
see
it was free you didn't have to pay
anything interesting
there's someone here saying i worked in
uh child protection for a few years
and boot camp atc
um is definitely abuse yeah
i mean that's terrifying that the first
people to come into your home where your
parents are where you're supposed to be
safe and kidnap you essentially is like
that's lifelong traumatic there's
someone i got sent away when i was 15
and it really changed the trajectory of
my life for the worst
i'm so sorry and i and i it just it
doesn't at 15 you're still a kid but
it's such a betrayal of trust your
parents the one people that you're
supposed to trust to be safe and
everything have authorized these people
who are probably closer to criminals
than you are to come kidnap you and take
you to a horrible place it's just
i can't get into the rationale of people
that do that it's sad sad i think my
cousin is more
um i guess for lack of a better term uh
messed up than she was before
and it's really sad yeah you know it's
super traumatic i can only imagine i
don't know how you wouldn't be more
messed up after that
yeah well it's like you know there's
that great line from shawshank he had to
go to prison and become a criminal
right
great movie
free with youtube premium anyway let's
keep watching
of a car and drove me
out to the middle of nowhere this this
was in my junior year high school and i
never returned
do you ever feel like you wish you had
different parents no never never
sometimes i just wish that i could have
like been more anonymous
do you think you would have succeeded to
the same degree on social media if you
were a blank slave probably not that's
why i'm saying it has it has pros and
cons that's advantages and disadvantages
you know what i mean people assume that
because like my dad is super famous that
like everybody would like want to be my
friend and be like kissing my ass and
that just wasn't the case
if i walk into a room and someone's like
oh you know who that is that's that's
tom hanks's son the the logical reaction
is for someone to assume that like i
must be like a real cocky arrogant
spoiled brat like piece of [ __ ] like
people were inclined to hate my guts i
just internalized it and it just
developed me to kind of like have a
really negative chip on my shoulder
and uh be very kind of like defensive
just on edge
around like meeting new people
pussycloth
[Music]
so thinking back to your earliest
memories in life what is the earliest
instance you can remember that someone
treated you super weird because you were
tom hanks son i was nice with foursquare
i beat this kid in a game of foursquare
and he got super pissed that i beat him
and he was like you just think you're so
[ __ ] cool cause your dad's famous you
know what i mean and i was like
man that had nothing to do with it you
know what i mean yeah i realized then at
that moment that like me being like who
i am like meant nothing to me but it
meant a lot to other people
i find that pretty interesting inside
actually i do feel for chet i do too
yeah i do feel for chad i like chat i'm
i'm not even gonna hate on chat even
though he threatened me also somebody
said there's a community on facebook
called breaking code silence if you went
to a program like this join us oh
wow so there's like communities of
yeah wow
yeah that's
crazy you basically pay people to go
abuse your kids
incredible
[Music]
actually i take it back i'd send this
kid to boot camp
i would send him to boot camp at a
heartbeat
coming up around the six minute mark
you're going to want to skip about a
minute and a half of the video oh that
much
[Music]
what was the first way you expressed
yourself okay well i started writing
bars rhymes
whatever you want to call it
15. do you remember what your first bars
were first things first man we talking
about the hearse i got mad gifts but
this verse about the curse or when life
stops in the good times sees debris and
dice grandma rest in peace that was the
yeah so i'm skipping the booties
7 28.
skipping the booty
oh you just saw a bit of booty in the
thumb preview i don't know dude i don't
really know i just know a little bit uh
big up the whole island massive giano
star big of the youth then it's not what
you say it's how you say it make the
king go up
seven
what'd you think about the picture of
adele with the jamaica brawl
adele adele adele
you're not sending me a printer from a
long time but after i see a picture out
there
it sweetened me that was tight
i'm literally making a conscious effort
now to not quit dude andrew's such a
great editor yeah i love how he edits
it's amazing or give a [ __ ] he's also
really good at this kind of interviewing
and letting people just be themselves
like balance that uh louis thoreau vibe
where he's like
it almost just comes off as innocent
no judgment absolutely very
very talented young man he's gonna go
far in life for sure
there was a flyer yes yes
about what these people are possibly
saying or talking about
and then that kind of created a whole
different beast it's like people like
i'll be getting like this last week
am i getting a haircut
and my barber's like dude so uh so
you're tom makes his son no you really
thomas's son tell your dad to come in
here and it's like yeah dude for sure
do you actually think i'm going to tell
my dad that
like that's what that's the kind of [ __ ]
me and my dad talk about
but but people are so oblivious dude
they don't even stop to think about how
many billions of [ __ ] millions of times
have people told me that
you know what my favorite movie of your
dads is and i'm like what but you're
like forrest gump oh [ __ ] that's that's
tom hey son right there yeah look at him
that's him he tied it up get his workout
on
before he's gone it's a classic
right here how do you feel about the
fact that you just met tom hank's son
hey it's cool [ __ ] has you seen your uh
music video yeah
favor i showed my mom and my dad they
were like this could be this this is
like a cardi b
what are your aspirations for your music
career pop off i'm trying to be doing
shows all [ __ ] summer dude
have you written any bars recently that
you're hyped about you can spit for us i
could just spit some freestyle bars for
sure that'd be good okay we're showing
on my balcony i'm doing an interview
with you andrew
you got a biker hat off what's that
about
is it for the clout let's say route 66 i
pick up sticks i might pick up your
[ __ ] in a fly ass whip
i might go do some burpees right outside
of my [ __ ] you know what i mean cause
i'm trying to get a pack out of this
this is very bad
and the freestyle part is very bad i
have to say
it was amazing too
someone one of the comments was so good
they go
andrew's affinity for people to
freestyle around them
[Music]
you know what i mean it's white boy
summer i showed her real you know what i
mean
it's not it's not on you it's in you you
know what i'm saying
you know what i mean i've been that dude
and i'm just
as he does this
so i'm going to write it i just recite
it and every time i recite it i ignite
it
because it's lit
and i'm really with the shits and we
don't give two shits
[Music]
empty out the clip
[Music]
white boy summer on a broke [ __ ]
[Music]
dude there's so many times how can it be
i don't know
breaking news breaking news you're
watching channel 5.
[Music]
define illuminati
uh an elite cabal of child sex
traffickers who control the uh the
global banking system
no
we're at venice beach
that's chet
i'm andrew
he's doing a hundred burpees i can only
do 30 but tomorrow i'm going to do 40.
so give me all of you in exchange for me
follow me hey pop that [ __ ] up man
yeah come on man
such a character
yeah i was like dude i could have
watched an hour yeah there you have it
chet hanks everybody shout out the
island pick up them ufo
and channel five
anything else
uh
chanel five chanel five okay i'm about
to kill this mother
there's actually a channel chanel all
right
i guess that's it was there anything
else we were supposed to do
oh
no shout out the island we did it all
pick up them you're flying pussycloth
boss man
all right
okay that's that thank you everybody all
right peace and love peace and love it's
been a glorious uh week
thank you there's a good chance that the
new show will be airing this sunday
there's a good chance there'll be a
fourth episode this sunday
but i'm not even gonna say 100.
but thank you for watching this one
thank you for watching
and congratulations eli
[Applause]
it's friday baby remember your twitter
likes are public
never forget never anybody didn't know
come on now
all right have a great weekend everyone
hopefully we'll see you on sundays
[Music]